all right let's get started here
um
so just to remind everybody that uh
the schedule
for early bills was pushed up a week so
we have to get them out this week
okay
and um
uh
uh why was it pushed up a week there was
something about scheduling the exact the
actual
session
and so that the session was going to be
the 17th i believe
so uh of february yeah so i'm not sure
what the what the the issue was but they
we were told to you know get get
everything out this week
so
so you need to do what you're told
i
generally do what i'm told yes
no i had scheduled so that we could
exact tomorrow
if necessary
so we could we didn't i give it give it
you know another
we might need more subcommittees right
there's another issue which is up north
there's going to be an ice storm
so
so you might not want to be here
tomorrow well i'll do everything i can
but i'm not gonna drive in a sleet storm
okay okay
all right um so we'll start out uh the
first one up is the
uh
uh what what do we have here uh no
that's the public hearing where's my sub
where's my subcommittee work schedule
here we have okay the mental health
parity all right
so we have in front of us two different
amendments on the mental health parity
one is that i drew up
related to
the issue of
what is going on in terms of getting
whether we really have adequate coverage
in in terms of network adequacy
and
my my approach is to
say that we can solve
the fact that the physician the mental
health providers are not getting paid
enough if we put pressure on in
ensuring that the network is truly
adequate and there's certainly enough
providers there
so um i now have another amendment here
in front of me so uh representative leno
you want to tell us what's in this
amendment
sure thank you very much mr chairman
he's going to join join me also this
morning so in in what you've got uh
stapled in front of you john
um mr chair is is actually three
amendments
yeah because this this came
as a result of um
of negotiating um um an amendment with
uh with the with anthem uh particularly
with uh
with um with ms rogers
uh
we we prepared um amendment four one one
which is at the top of uh of that staple
sheet
and that
basically thins down the uh the bill
quite substantially
and
addresses directly i think the
uh the some of the criticism we heard
during the last work session with
regards to requiring the same rate so it
gets rid of the word rates
in section 2 roman 2
and replaces that with
a statutory reference to the network
adequacy standard in the state so now
you would have that reference
under the the mental health parity
act in section two
that that references 420 j7
so
so provide benefit for treatment and
diagnosis of certain biologically based
mental illnesses under the same access
standards established in 420 j colon 7
comma terms and conditions
which are no less extensive than
coverage provided for any other type of
any other type of health care for
physical illness so now we've now we
we we're not requiring the same rates
but at least the same access and
availability and i think that's that's
what came through loud and clear
from the uh from last week's work
session the second
version so
so these these sort of came over
sequentially
from anthem and um uh we're um
and we're fine with this so this is now
amendment 412
where um where some of the language down
on the
section 2 roman 2
lines 28 and 29
are
sort of jiggled around a little bit to
read better and um and ms rogers i think
can
can speak to um to the the rationale
behind that it uh it doesn't change
anything materially from the from the
amendment i just spoke about
and then the third one which came over
after i had
sent the the other two
up to the up over to
ols
to be prepared
strikes section 1 roman 2
which is a reporting requirement
to
which would require the insurance
department to
to investigate violations of the
wellstone domenici parity act
and the reason section two has been
struck in this third version
uh is because my understanding is that
there is a senate bill
senate bill 373
that is um has been put in i believe at
the request of the department uh but uh
mr brannon i think can uh can can
clarify that
uh and so it would would not necessarily
be required to be in uh in this bill
so so what we're offering mr chair
is um is uh is basically a bill that
that addresses that improves the mental
health uh parity act by requiring
insurers
to comply with access standards access
and availability standards that are in
law today but in the the managed
health care law but also apply those
access and availability standards to the
mental health parity um act so
theoretically that should already be law
it is law but it's and it's it's in the
manage it's just not referenced in the
uh okay so this is
i think in the words of my former
chairman this is belts and suspenders
reaffirming something that's already in
the stack could be in case it's in case
it has gotten lost and uh and
we certainly we certainly heard um heard
substantial testimony
to the lack of uh access and
availability i mean if i'm if i'm a
parent and my my child's got an earache
i'm i'm i'm in the uh the physician's
office in 15 minutes right and we need
to have that so
i just want you to know when you what
you just said there was what the purpose
of my amendment was
was to make sure there was more
availability access and availability
okay so notwithstanding that uh we
um i mean i i guess theoretically if if
i find out that section two
tyler just reaffirms it's already
current law
so all it is is it's kind of feel good
but it reaffirms what we're doing
okay
i wouldn't i i guess i would not
particularly have a problem of adding
this to to
my amendment that that section um the
preamble part no i don't i don't see any
you know legislative
need for the preamble part
uh but if this if this paragraph
makes everybody feel a little better
that that we're we're reaffirming what's
current law then um i i can't
particularly have a problem with it so
so mr chair do we do do we think it's
worth worth it for the uh for the
committee to hear from uh the insurance
department and also maybe i don't know
if we have anybody with uh that
represents providers with respect to uh
to uh the uh the elements from the
amendment that you had proposed oh right
well i can see how providers might not
like to have to make that phone call but
if if
they're making they're taking phone
calls when people are calling up and
saying will you take me as a patient and
they have to say no
why wouldn't it be easier just to call
up the insurance
company at the moment you're not taking
patients anymore and tell them yeah i i
but i think it's just worth worth it
hearing from uh from them if we're
putting up well we're very limited on
time here yep okay so is there any
questions from the committee for
representative leno
saying none thank you very much for your
testimony okay tyler you're on
yeah yeah
yeah
could i just be clear about what we're
doing yes i don't have um your amendment
mr j uh i i it's it's over here i'm
sorry i didn't no it wasn't we're going
to request an another amendment that
would be um
we could be between now if we get this
resolved we could have something for the
full committee at
one o'clock 1 15. yep at one o'clock
okay yep thanks very much yes please
distribute it
yeah okay no problem
okay so tyler so
so theoretically and i'm correct in
saying that uh access standards
establish that that's this the 420 j7 is
universal it covers
everything but by putting it into this
paragraph it reaffirms that once again
those procedures need to be followed
yeah that's correct so the network
adequacy section is statute is
relatively general our administrative
rule that deals with network adequacy
which has specific time and distance
standards potentially by county um there
are actually services are divided into
those that are most specialized those
are least specialized and you should
have the closest proximity to those
services yep there are about 30 services
in what we call considered core up there
with primary care physical therapy about
half of them are behavior health
services so it's actually fairly robust
when we look at kind of the network
adequacy standard related to mental
health when i say behavioral health i'm
actually including sud but the point is
yes we have a network adequate sustainer
general very detailed rule very strong
standards for access to
sud and mental services
okay great
uh then in terms of my amendment which
you drew up can you just briefly
describe what this amendment does um
that would address the
it is currently required by federal law
that carriers update their their
provider directories and do so with a
indicator as to whether the provider is
accepting new patients however to the
extent that we regulate the carrier if
the carrier does not have current
information from the provider then that
creates a certain challenge in making
sure that that kind of information is
accurate so the amendment would make it
clear that through a provider contract
standard in other words the contract
between the insurer and the provider
would require the provider to tell the
the carrier within i think it was two
days right in a timely fashion actually
30 days yeah timely fashion uh that
they're no longer accepting new patients
right okay
any questions here
representative bartlett okay i'm sorry
um i just gonna clarify who who is
actually gonna be responsible for
amending
all these amendments i will take care of
getting the amendment dropped okay got
it
thank and um do we have a number on the
third amendment
representative luna
okay
but okay we're going to coordinate that
before 1 15.
right
i was going to as uh assume we didn't
want to do the third amendment
i assume we didn't want to do the third
amendment so
what are you proposing so i'm proposing
that we uh
uh take
my amendment and add
your um
the section 2 roman 2 act access
standards established in rsa420 and then
also
and then they use the effective date yes
that's what i'm proposing
you're okay with that
they're okay with that okay does anybody
have a problem with that speak now
forevermore hold your peace do you need
me to do anything
um well if you want to run over and have
the amendment drawn i'm sure
i'm sure chris
i was going to have my staffer do it but
if you want to do it
is education not meeting today
his education meeting today
are you guys meeting today in education
okay so we want you to get back to work
could i just ask representative luna
you're going to be here at 1 15.
okay i just think we should look look
over there
once we have it done
okay thanks so much all right does every
so is everybody clear on what uh we're
proposing uh to take the uh amendment
that has my name on it and adding in
on the amendment that's o four one one h
which has represented bartlett at the
top to add in the section two and three
of the bill
okay we're all set um since we don't
have an official amendment from me we're
not going to vote but that's
that's where we're going to go with okay
chris do you have
christine do you have have you got that
what we're doing
adding section two and three from this
amendment
the bartlett amendment
from
adding that to
my amendment 297.
so that will change the effective date
change
on that it changes to 2
to make that a new 2
and then there will be a three the
effective date is january first
okay so that's incorporating
all of what's in
um
oh four one two right now
one one or one two
so section two row
four
because that was written in nicer
fashion
okay tyler you're the one who wants to
enforce it which one's a better better
written paragraph
i just want to make sure that kristen's
got the right instruction oh i agree
okay right
so all i'm going to do is i'm going to
take i'm going to take
mine
and i'm going to scratch this out and
say 2 is going to be
it's going to be
it's going to be um
section
once i write this down i'll read it to
everybody so everybody section 2
roman rule 2 of
and section 3
is effective date
january
okay so if everybody has my amendment in
their hand
yes okay
uh what we would do in my amendment is
change section two
which is effective date
and that section two is now going to be
part
section two
roman numeral two
of amendment number o four one two
and section three would be the effective
date january 1 2023
beautiful
all right everybody got that
speak now forevermore hold your peace if
you have a problem with it
you will we'll have that we will we
don't vote on anything unless you have
it in hand
i i have a i have an experience of where
that didn't happen that way not in my
community our committee but it happened
and it was did not it did not go well
okay
next up
yeah that's where we're not hearings yet
okay so next one is next subcommittee
why am i missing my subcommittee sheet
here
12 37.
okay house bill 1237 we have an
amendment for it
has that been distributed
is that is that yeah 12 37 yep
okay so uh 12 37 while she's
distributing the amendment uh you can
briefly describe it again this is my one
this is my amendment
and that was in our discus the bill was
to um reduce
the tobacco requirement uh percentage
requirement of a cigar bar
um from uh
60 to 50 uh for two years
and then
and sunset and put it back to where it
was
in the discussion of the bill
we
we talked a little bit about what was uh
the 60 percent based on
and
for better for worse the wisdom of the
legislature when they passed the cigar
bar legislation
at
the beginning
uh emphasized uh that the it was
expected that that 60 percent
um would be just to back cigar type
products
and in particular it specifically said
uh cigarettes
and loose tobacco sales could not be
included in the 60 percent
um so in thinking about that i i'm
thinking that that doesn't make sense
because if they didn't have the wine if
they weren't in this business if they
were just a tobacco shop i'm sure that
they would be selling cigarettes
and so why would we mess with with the
fundamental business model they should
be having which is they're in the
business of selling tobacco products
which includes cigarettes and loose
tobacco so basically all we did is move
the
exemption line
and move it up to the accepted line
any discussion
any questions
yes representative bartlett okay thank
you mr chair so um all this was doing
was clarifying what we had in discussion
during larry can you just move a little
i need to talk about that um
i hate this seating arrangement
so this is just clarifying the
discussion we had in the subcommittee
about how
cigarette
sales are
audited is that correct right and then
the next question i have is um
so does this allow a cigar bar if the
tobacco sales go up to be able to sell
more liquor
uh but i'm wondering theoretically that
is true they could still their way of of
increasing liquor sales
they could sell more liquor if yeah if
if all of a sudden you know having all
this they're 60 but i i'm pretty sure
that that it really doesn't that that
the law wasn't driving that per se
because
once we said above 60 it didn't matter
as long as they were selling plenty of
tobacco products
then there was never any pressure about
how much alcohol they sold
right so the fact that we're
raising it doesn't mean all of a sudden
they're going to go out and find more
wine tasting you know whatever alcohol
tasting customers
see i'm i'm wondering if it's not a
backdoor way of allowing more liquor
sales in that that's where the profit is
yeah
i guess i'd like to hear from the liquor
commission what their thoughts are on
this uh okay there he is
so yes representative johnson but they
still have to sell 60
of tobacco so it doesn't it doesn't
change anything
it just gives them more of a tobacco
stuff that they can sell
to meet that 60 marker
right but it also when that gross
revenue goes up it's also going to allow
for um higher liquor sales
increase liquor sales right
thank you
my name is lieutenant matthew culver the
new hampshire state liquor commission
division of enforcement licensing thank
you
mr chairman and committee members
that is correct uh fundamentally when
you increase the revenue for the 60
requirement in cigars or cigar related
products
you have the
availability to increase the alcohol
sales based on the data that we have on
on these specific
business models that have obtained
recently obtained the cigar bar license
we can
definitely
draw a conclusion
that
the
this those models are experiencing
difficulties and compliance
what we based on our data we can't draw
the conclusion
that that is based or has a propensity
to be based on the increase of tobacco
or alcohol sales
so
just because you are increasing the
amount of alcohol sales doesn't mean
that they're going to
increase the amount of violations they
have in fact with adding these products
into
the law
they're going to be
uh there will be a larger chance of them
to be
um less non-compliant with a 60
requirement right
further question you may include
so
do we have even anecdotal
information about
how many cigarettes are
sold from a typical cigar bar i i know
that hasn't been a
focus for them but they are available
we have some data on that it's not
broken down by what kind of tobacco
product it is
but um
we do have that data yes
so the question is
has
given the current situation with the 60
have businesses been saying no we can't
sell you wine anymore this month because
we've already hit our 60 percent
have you ever had anybody who actually
says to us 40 or 40 that that well the
ratios were were out of whack that we
got we got to shut down because of it
yes that has occurred and in
establishments that are that know that
they're close to their 60 percent
requirement
60 40 ratio
they
monitor those sometimes on a daily basis
per night that they're open
so
yes there are circumstances where
they limit drink amounts to two drinks
because if they serve four drinks their
60 ratio is going to be
way out of line and if they're way out
of line more than
say a week
for their
quarterly reports
they're going to be
by the end of that quarter massively out
of compliance
okay representative
so does the commission take a position
on this um amendment because it sounds
like your auditors had different ways of
currently have different ways of
interpreting is that correct
different ways of interpreting that
other than cigar tobacco sales
because it sounded like some were
including the cigarettes and some were
not
is that what we heard from testimony
the tobacco the cigarette were
specifically excluded from that so the
law was specific on what was included in
the cigar related products
so does the commission take a position
on this amendment
i believe that the commission is is
remaining neutral on this yeah no as far
as i know they're neutral
i think the commission would be frank
the commission's more worried about the
hookahs
and hookah
is not as what i was concerned was loose
tobacco but evidently it's not tobacco
it's some other herbs and spices that so
so in that sense we're not
going we're not allowing that which that
which is what the commission's already
concerned with
yes representative
thank you thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh loose tobacco
to me would include pipe tobacco which
is a an offering a lot of cigar shops um
and they also sell pipes that could be a
hundred dollars or more um
should we're including cigar ashtrays
should we include uh pipes for the loose
tobacco just just asking a question
and thank you for the question certainly
that that is um a possibility to to look
at to be included in in those types of
products um just for point of
clarification there department of
revenue does
tax
uh shisha or hookah okay on uh
as loose tobacco
oh okay so it is loose tobacco then i i
think there's a discrepancy in the in
the
definitions of that um i know there's a
representative from health and human
services here who
has it
under their
uh definitions have a different
interpretation of that
okay
all right well i think i was just trying
to minimize what we're taking from one
line and moving up to the x line uh but
it sounds like that we need to wait to
the dust settles on those
those issues in terms of uh
what
what what is in and what is out and and
maybe we want to
want to revisit this again in the future
that may be beneficial to look at what
these definitions uh
entail i know there's a discrepancy and
definition between dra
and
department of health and human services
but at the very
basic level um including these products
would assist cigar bar licensees in
helping reach that 60 percent right
maybe we should do just cigarettes and
not lose tobacco
pipe tobacco you know i know that you
have five years and to me twice it was
definitely
all right so let's leave it like this
and then and and then once once that has
been refereed
between the hhs and dra then maybe we
can revisit this in the future
are you okay with that representative
bartlett
i have some discomfort over the fact
that
this is probably going to make it
easier to sell more liquor
however i don't feel like i'm in a
position to
dictate
how the cigar bar stays financially
right viable
um
like assuming we we have this whole
statue wrapped around lodging
we don't henry's not in the room is he
um
but i guess we could check it but i i my
assumption is that the lodging in the
restaurant who really is the one that's
most concerned
about them you know having this liquor i
i would assume they're happy because we
still have not allowed them to sell food
and and so i would assume that they
would be happy but we can certainly i
could check up with them before we take
this up
okay
all right uh
anybody else have any other discussion
thank you very much thank you question
on this amendment
uh so we do have an amendment in front
of us so we could vote as a subcommittee
on this amendment
so who's who's on the subcommittee the
business committee
subcommittee for
liquor
we've got um bolio van houghton and we
have a
um
sub in me
um patuchik abramson
and herbert oh no i'm sorry not herbert
he's in business
so i'm subbing for van halen
and who do you have somebody subbing for
abramson right so
representative greeson's gonna sub so
there's only five of us okay
all right uh so representative patusik
second by representative hunt moves out
to pass on the amendment is there any
discussion on the amendment seeing none
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one
two three four five okay
all those in favor about to pass as
amended please raise your hand
one two three four five okay we're good
to go all right
all right what's next
okay
all right so
uh 1502 1503 and 1504 all right so as
some of you may know just to make sure
everybody knows what we're doing here
um 1503 even though i scheduled it with
the other bills
as though um because it was a crypto
bill and i thought really if we're going
to talk crypto we should be be unified
in our conversation
with them it turns out 1503 did not have
that evil uh fiscal note to it
the five million dollar fiscal note and
so therefore did not have an early
departure date
so it is the 1503 does not have to be
out of this committee until february
10th
so that gives us a month to do what okay
so 1502 is uh we already very well so we
have 1502 and that not least 1502 and
okay but
you know it still has a fiscal note is
that correct
both of these had the same fiscal note
attached to it okay got it okay
so what would i like to do uh if if it
will humor of the subcommittee is that
is the one that really was the driver
for the fiscal note because it was
creating a separate division within the
banking department and um i think
everyone pretty much agrees that that's
probably not a good idea for new
hampshire so i would then uh entertain
it's uh once we finish with this that we
would want to just kill 1504 and really
send the message that no we're not
interested in creating that division
the uh 1502
um had some of the language and and then
in 1503
was obviously securities related
but what we do know now is that
we want to go forward with a ucc model
legislation which uh theoretically in
the next two or three years i don't know
how many years before they officially
announced it
that every state is going to have the
same similar statute so the advantages
here is that new hampshire will be the
first
to have a ucc statute related to crypto
and i the sense of urgency i feel about
this is is i am i am shocked in awe
that how many financial institutions
already are doing it i mean i was
looking at my paypal account and it's
telling me yeah it's in the business of
doing crypto um i know trust departments
uh absolutely are
jumping at the bit to be carrying it in
people's portfolios
so if that is true then that that makes
our sense of urgency of doing the ucc
that much more anyways is to you know to
have that so um the plan would be today
would be to uh dispose of 1502 and 1504
because they're early bills
and that way 1503 will then be the uh
our crypto bill that we will then take
up um by the end of the first week of
february
this is the first week of february
excuse me first week of march i'm sorry
okay chairman
yes
i think did you so i thought you were
saying we were
taking away 1503 and 1504 and we're
gonna use 1502. no
no
okay let me try again okay
1502 i think we should interim study it
so that we always have something that's
in still in the committee
we will take up
march
first week of march
1504 i think we should just dispose of
today
this sounds good
okay yeah all right
yeah i i'm sorry i could have misspoke
and obviously i spoke about the dates
okay all right so we'll start out with
um okay who's on this side
right here okay
okay so um
osborne's not here so i'll replace him
with you
okay
and
is able
able's here
so fargo who's replacing fargo
and representative herbert and mcaleer
okay and ham you're on this one okay and
him all right so representative patusek
seconded by representative bartlett
moves in exceeding the legislate on
house bill 1504
is that mission
motion clear
15 right tail okay all those in favor
please raise your hand
one two three four five six seven eight
nine okay do we have that many people in
this one two three four five six seven
eight eight to zero
okay
eight to zero okay
um
all right next is
this one that's 1504. yeah okay uh the
next motion uh representative patusek
happened by representative bartlett
moves that
b interim study
any discussion on that motion seeing
none all those in favor raise your hand
okay however i've got nine
i've got hunt osborne ham johnson abel
weston fargo herbert mcclear and i'm um
subbing for weston i'm sorry fargo nine
zero nine zero okay they're nine zero
nine zero two okay
perfect well that's it
all right
okay
and now
what else do
1503 is going to be we're putting that
off 1503 we're not taking that up today
and and like i say right now 1503
is i
have
we have courtney for legislative
services
tom conley from the business
division of the secretary of state's
office
is our ucc expert
and hopefully that within a month will
will they will do their shake their
magic and make it happen okay got it
representative herbert
we just killed 1504
1503 we just interim study it so we have
a vehicle for going forward 1502. excuse
me
and 1503 we're not taking up today
because uh we're we're going to be
holding on to that and working on that
some more the interim study is there a
time
certain
interim study bill if that if the house
concurs with that motion would mean that
we would keep that bill in committee and
we would probably revisit it next fall
and then by by october
of next year
we would have to say recommend or not
recommend for future legislation
so just so i got it straight
nothing's going to get passed until
there's further study
and discussion
on the cryptocurrency issue nothing is
good nothing we hope
that we will have a month from today
one month
we would have an amendment for 1503.
and in that amendment
we'll have the agreed upon language for
securities
and then the
attempt to put
create a new ucc chapter chapter 12
that will be
blockchain technology
all right so um
there is a there is the potential that
there would be a ucc
blockchain
i'm sorry yeah stay tuned that's where
yes ucc
we hope
to have in front of us
a month from now one month okay i just
you can vote against it then chris
you will get your chance to vote against
it
no i just
okay
any more discussion all right so oh we
do have one more thing
oh of course the most important
important one right 1469.
okay so we do have an amendment for 1469
and that is being distributed
um
yeah so
yeah
all right so the amendment should say
three four two have my name on it and
it'll say three four two
thank you
okay uh so what uh 342 does is it uh
basically replace the entire bill so
we'll start with that concept we've
replaced the entire
original bill
it changes the title to the bill
relative prohibited acts for banks
credit unions and businesses
and amends the bill with two sections
section one section two
section one is in the banking statute
section two is in the consumer
protection statute
so brandy do you want to
say anything
and you since i'm the only one in the
room who knows who you are you might
want to introduce yourself
yeah do you have to make sure the mic is
on and pull it close to you
so they can hear you at home
yeah the button there should be a button
there yeah
red is on
camera's on there
opposite of what they do in the
courthouses yes
everybody hear me okay yes
morning members of the committee mr
chairperson my name is brandon garad i'm
a senior assistant attorney general uh
also the chief of the consumer
protection and anti-trust bureau at the
department of justice um so i am here
just to point out some observations
uh that the department of justice has
about 1469
not to speak to the merit of the bill
itself or the underlying intention of it
but simply speak
as mr chairperson you pointed out
about 50 of this amendment would be
placed under new hampshire's consumer
protection act
uh the consumer protection bureau of the
department of justice are the enforcers
of the consumer protection act so
anytime something is being added or
amended in the consumer protection act
as the enforcer i look at it as a matter
of enforceability
if somebody were to file a complaint
with our office alleging a violation of
this statute would the department of
justice be able to meaningfully
investigate
and determine whether or not a violation
has occurred
and i think there are some great
concerns with the way that this
amendment is currently written and that
many complaints under or allegations
made under uh the way this is worded now
would largely be unenforceable by the
department of justice now i'll give you
an example of what i mean
you know currently the consumer
protection act gives us the ability when
somebody files a complaint at the
department of justice
there is subpoena authority under the
consumer protection act that allows us
to investigate
interview witnesses take testimony
subpoena documents in order to make sure
that if somebody's making a complaint
against somebody before the department
of justice is bringing civil or criminal
charges forward we're able to
corroborate what's being said we're able
to build a case and we're able to
clearly show that a violation of the
consumer protection act has happened and
that there are unfair and deceptive acts
or practices that are being committed
to
to make it a unfair and deceptive act or
practice to discriminate against an
individual in the course of business
based on these various factors absent
some sort of written policy by the
business
that the attorney general's office was
able to subpoena and review um and
so in that circumstance it would be
enforceable if a business keeps a
written policy that says you know we're
going to treat this group of people
different than this group of people
right that would be enforceable we'd be
able to subpoena the business we'd be
able to subpoena the business owner in
ask them about written policies ask
employees about written policies and to
the extent that those written policies
existed
this would potentially be enforceable
but absent something like that
if a business is taking an action
against somebody and the purpose that
the business is behind their action is
really the the
employee or the business owners
subjective intent in doing so absent a
confession by the bad actor in that case
that their motivation for taking the
action that they took
was in fact one of the factors listed in
the statute the attorney general's
office would be left without any
recourse to be able to investigate to
determine um what the underlying purpose
of the action was
so i just don't want to create the
impression that if this is passed and
complaints are made to the attorney
general's office that this is something
that's going to be easily investigated
and easily prosecuted
we take our responsibility
in you know investigating and bringing
charges especially criminal charges very
seriously
and we can only do so if we have
evidence to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that a crime has occurred
and in this case we would have to prove
not only that an action took place
some sort of discriminatory act taken
against a customer in the course of
business but that the underlying purpose
of that action was in fact to
discriminate based on any of the factors
that are listed in the statute so it's
not just enough that an act takes place
but we would have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt in a criminal
case
and by preponderance of the evidence in
a civil case that the purpose behind
that action was in fact because of an
individual's
political affiliations or philosophical
ideas
and there's no real way to do that
unless it's either in writing or the
person is willing to give a full
confession and say you know this was my
intention i'm happy to take a question
okay so before i take this question
because i'm pretty sure i know where
he's going so i just want to ask this
question of you sure would you believe
that this legislation is built around
someone actually publicly admitting
that they are
uh discriminating for instance deutsche
bank said that they refused to do loans
with the trump
company
if some so if a business were to admit
to a practice like that and this statute
wasn't in fact sure we would be able to
enforce it in that limited circumstance
but that would basically be the only
circumstance exactly i would i just said
would you believe this legislation
intent is really people really are going
to be public about their discrimination
and that's what we really want to make
sure it does not occur yeah i understood
i just wanted to you know i i imagine
that if this legislation were to pass
um what would happen
is that we would receive a lot of
complaints from people that felt that
they were treated unfairly in the course
of business throughout the state um and
that that was as a result of their
personal ideologies political beliefs
facebook posts whatever have you and you
know if we look at that complaint and
it's a business that hasn't made any
public statements right about you're
discriminating against a certain class
of people or a certain group of people
and we reach out to the business and say
hey can you respond to this complaint
and they say no we're not going to
that ends our ability to investigate
that type of complaint so i think those
concerns uh
to the extent that you know
that type of enforceability can be
tightened up or can be drafted in a way
where the attorney general's office
would be able to
take enforcement action or investigate
those types of complaints i think that's
a concern that the committee should
think so
obviously one of the other uh
what do i say avenues of resolution to a
statute is the right of private action
so i'm sure there are plenty of times
you have said to people who called and
complained listen we're never going to
be able you know unless you've got a
smoking gun there's nothing we can do
but you there's nothing stopping you
from suing
that business
that is true mr chairperson but you know
we
are the authority on consumer protection
in the state and the public looks to us
to enforce the consumer protection act
so we certainly want to be in a position
to enforce it whenever there is a
violation and there are unfair and
deceptive acts of practice is occurring
i don't want to be in a situation where
we're receiving an onslaught of
complaints and we have to continually
tell consumers you know this is
simply not enough evidence there's
nothing we can do at that point it looks
like you know your the people's consumer
protection bureau has failed them and
it's telling them to you know go to
court and do it yourself we don't like
to be in that position no i i hear you i
hear you but i i guess i i guess i'm i'm
i'm not i'm not sure that is going to
occur so but i hear you and that you
know if we if we did see this an
overwhelming problem then i you know i'd
say yes we probably could say something
to to people like don't please don't
bother us if you don't have evidence but
um at this point i i don't you know we
have to we have to assume that people
that the the intent of the legislation
is from the sponsors is that is that
this is
uh that the these guilty parties will be
public about their position that they
are they've been publicly
uh
i don't say browbeated into doing that
so we want to just make on record that
we don't want that to happen
uh representative terry
uh thank you mr chairman so first if i
may ask a question of you
when you say publicly
i i understand that in a couple of
different ways one is that it's out in
the open for people to see right or
public do you mean by publicly that it's
actually a stated policy it had he had a
you you mean state of health yes okay so
because public means it's in view
uh stated it can also mean that yes you
mean stated all right so i have a
question for the yes okay sir thank you
so um i understand what you're saying i
think i understand what you're saying
with respect to
investigatory powers and
would it be enough though
if a company did not
advertise or state publicly
a particular
potentially discriminatory practice
would it be enough for the department if
it observed a pattern
potentially i mean that is that is a
method that we
use in evaluating consumer complaints
follow
so that now would not require subpoena
power that would
all you
all you'd have to see would be a
pattern of behavior that suggested
discrimination
if it was a consistent enough and a
continuous enough pattern there is a
possibility that that could lead to
enough for us to move forward yes but it
would all depend on you know the
complaints would have to be very similar
and they would have to be you know
so that would be in addition to
something stated
yes yes another criteria or data point
representative greeson
thank you mr and thank you for answering
our questions uh how many businesses
have written policies to discriminate
against any of the other protected
groups
i i can't
discriminate and answer that question
this morning unfortunately and does
discrimination still occur despite
having laws on the books that say thou
shalt not discriminate
i'm sorry can you repeat your question
does discrimination still occur
does any discrimination occur
a discrimination of course occurs and
and when you investigate this
discrimination how many of those places
that were alleged to have discriminated
have on their paul in their books a
policy written policy that you know
we're going to discriminate against
x y or z group
discrimination is not currently a part
of the consumer protection act so we do
not do we do have a civil rights bureau
in the attorney general's office human
rights commission yes but what i want to
say he mentioned earlier
that
it would have to be in a businesses
written policy that they're going to
discriminate against in order to be
enforceable this act or written it
doesn't have to be a written policy it
could be a it could be an advertised
policy it could be a pattern i'm i'm
using his words i know but that's that's
but how many businesses have a written
policy to discriminate
but again i can't answer that question i
haven't survived obviously the answer is
none
okay
representative rose
i have a quick question um on line 28
and i don't know if i'm asking this to
you mr chair um it says that when such
action is necessary for the physical
safety of the person the business or the
business employees should there be
something in there that would also
protect
the public
if the public would be
in danger
i mean i can give you an example
if somebody if somebody on let's say
okay i'll give you a what if somebody is
on social media advocating a um 911 type
attack in new hampshire
with that
i mean that's an extreme but is there is
there cause to put into also to protect
the public
representation you wrote this do you
know what what this paragraph was about
in in discussions with the with the um
with the
bankers association
uh
there may be an a need to
protect the employees of that business
from physical harm
and so
that's where this comes in
okay
as far as protecting the public
you're talking about a criminal
act
and
that then becomes a different issue
entirely
and so
this is not dealing with
criminal action in that regard so no
it's not necessary in the context uh if
somebody goes out and says i am going to
do something at this particular bank
because of x y or z uh then they that
that bank would have the ability to say
we're not going to do business with that
guy because of of clear threats against
specific uh that bank but just general
stupidity
uh
you know threats to the public how would
you define that but if there's any
credible threats that becomes a police
matter and not the business itself
okay representative herbert
um
my
i'm not inclined to
support this bill anyway but
my question is
haven't there been
rulings
what was it hobby lobby
where some businesses do discriminate
have
and they have been allowed to legally
discriminate
so i i'm a little confused here in terms
of
uh
non-discrimination what's i mean hobby
lobbies
was that a national uh law of some sort
because they didn't they didn't want to
uh
i can't remember yeah i'm not sure what
you're referring to but but at this
point we're just dealing with what's in
front of us
okay so
i'm just saying i i'm a little confused
because
it has already been done okay well we
understand all right representative
bartlett
thank you mr chair so i've got a
question um
if a bank decides that they're not going
to
for instance
loan money to
a fossil fuel producer
without this law
but would this actually would this bill
if it became law
allow you to
enforce
the discrimination
well in your hypothetical a bank has
decided not to loan to a fossil fuel
producer is it simply because they're a
fossil fuel producer yes they've decided
that i mean there's certain universities
there's certain
foundations that are not investing in
fossil fuel but if a fossil fuel
producer
came
came to a bank and said i want to borrow
money and they said no our policy is
that we're not going to
loan money to a fossil fuel producer
would you need this law in order to be
able to
um keep them from disre discriminating
so it's a it's a complicated question
assuming that it was a discrimination by
the bank
that fits one of the factors in this
statute yes this would allow us in that
circumstance to investigate
but again
you know it i assume that a lot of
decisions go into you know
significant business decisions like that
um we could ask the bank you know
we've received this report from this
company you've been denied uh they
believe it's discrimination you simply
are making a political statement about
your your your disbelief in the business
that they do what's your position
if the bank says no you know it was
largely a financial decision on our part
we don't have the ability to then do any
further investigation to show that
that's not actually the case because
what happened was a decision within the
inner workings of somebody's mind and
this is kind of the example that i'm
here to
point out to you you know if if the bank
said to us oh yeah you know we
definitely don't want to do business
with any fossil fuel producers and we
won't do it and we intend to
discriminate against them in the future
then yes that would be a violation of
this but you know
unless there is a full confession you
know yes we made this decision and yes
this was the motivation behind the
decision that we made this is very very
difficult to enforce so but i actually
want to respond too because there's two
ways to look at this question you
actually brought up two different type
of models one is if a a higher
institution decides to divest
in a stock
okay uh and they have made that
motivation that actually is permitted in
this statute so your investment
decisions and investing in something is
perfectly permitted right okay so
there's nothing barring you know harvard
from selling its oil stocks okay now the
next question was is if a bank were to
say we are not going to loan money
to
um somebody who's in the oil business
okay we decided went on to do it
well that wouldn't go to his department
that would go to amelia's department and
when milia would have to say to the bank
what is your rationale
they would have to document to the bank
department
why they have created that exclusion and
if they say we have decided through our
evidence that they are a bad investment
and we have documented where we have
cases where they the company uh failed
to to uh pay their loan they had
structural problems or whatever that if
they can make that example that the
banking that financial institution can
make a case
that that decision they're making
is based upon
past history of loans in that category
then it would be permitted so
this law is going to keep
would would potentially keep banks or
credit unions
or businesses
from being able to set their own policy
is that correct no it just reaffirms
that that they better have a rationale
for that policy just like insurance
company can't do use credit scoring
unless they can document that credit
scoring is a direct effect on your
ability
to pay for the insurance product
okay who has not asked this question
uh thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um
if it's a business decision then it's a
business decision it's not
discrimination can you expand on that
can i expand on that i mean can you i
mean
like if i owned a business and i didn't
want to do business with someone because
it's not it's not
a good business decision then a bank
could decide not to you know work with a
fossil fuel company because it's you
know not a good business decision
so i i think what you're pointing out
again highlights the enforceability
problems here which is that even once if
this is passed and this is a law in the
state of new hampshire businesses still
get to make those decisions based on you
know legitimate business factors that
aren't purely motivated by a
discriminatory purpose and what the
attorney general's office and the
banking commission would have to do in
investigating these types of reports is
determine conclusively by sufficient
evidence whether a specific decision was
purely discriminatory or was in some way
motivated by um a sound business
decision or a sound business practice
unrelated to discrimination and you know
the the reason coming for the committee
today
is to point out that
absent very rare circumstances where
there either is a written policy or an
express verbal policy or a full
confession by the business it's very
difficult if not enforceable
impossible for us to investigate and
enforce and prove which of the two it
was
i think that's very well stated thank
you
okay representative burroughs
clarification on this let's say that a a
business um their court their corporate
they have a corporate philosophy they
use an order or a mission statement to
attract customers um our mission is to
only invest in in clean energy
could they go after them for that
if they you know discriminated against a
fossil fuel company when that is the
mission of the bank and and it stated
clearly
again he doesn't cover banks
he does not do banks okay
the bank either banking the banking is
in particularly excluded
from the consumer price okay then
another another type so what i would say
is if i if i were in the oil business
and the bank has goes out and says we
don't
do business
with oil companies
and because that that we this is our our
approach to consumers
i would be wondering why would they be
pursuing that law you know loan from
that institution knowing full well that
institution has publicly said that they
don't do it but notwithstanding that
that that yes a in the financial
institution is going to say their that
bank is doing that for their marketing
approach
and therefore they can document why they
think that that's what the consumers
want and that's what they're doing and
that would be a rationale okay thanks
representative mike later thank you mr
chairman um
question this would have to do with
employment as well would it not
employment um
employment practices are business
practices right yes i believe it would
but it seems to me that it's it is
taking every bit of
subjectivity out of any choice
in other words it's really telling a
business what they can or cannot do
in other words if if i'm interviewing a
a prospect that i might want to hire uh
i just might not like the guy
and uh
well you can't that you can't use that
as an excuse
i don't like that
i don't like the cut of his gym okay um
and and he may have put
and i also think this is the possibility
that people might put something on their
social media that would sort of give
them an excuse to uh
to bring out a complaint i see that
happening as well i just find this
extremely vague i find it sort of
dictating to a business
how they should operate and i'm taking
all the subject subjectivity out of a
decision when i just don't like this guy
i don't like the cut of his jib
would you believe would you believe okay
so very much you know i think that the
the issue that you're seeing is more of
a policy issue uh which is a question
for you know the commission and the
legislature not for the attorney
general's office i'm just here to talk
about the enforceability if it was
passed in its current form so do you
have a question that's not bank related
yes
okay
first of all
this is not just
we've been looking at it as business to
business transactions and we need to
break it down to the individual person
because there's coming a time when
somebody's going to be going to work one
day and they're going to stop to put gas
in their car and their their their their
card their debit card is going to get
declined not because they don't have
money in the bank but because they drive
that's a banking quit that's a banking
question no no hold on hold on debit
card is a banking question i understand
it but it's all because they drive a
fossil fueled car and they have to drive
to work and if somebody is determined
that they drive too far to get to work
and their job is not important
okay that that's a would you believe
question that's a would you believe
question but it goes beyond that
to
you know it's this is how how we we had
the the attorney excuse me the
um
oh my goodness um what's his position
dude we're really tight on time the
surgeon general of the united states
came out this is an official now
from the from the biden administration
itself calling for private business
to censor
a private citizen
this the surgeon general called for
spotify to censor joe rogan
okay
up until joe rogan made a comment
that
the surgeon general didn't like
joe rogan was fine
okay
but the point is we now have an official
federal government
policy
calling for
the censorship
through the use of a business
so now the government is now telling the
business we want you to censor this guy
it doesn't matter why
the federal government is now telling a
private business to censor now at this
point
spotify has said
we're going to tell neil young to go
pound sand and we're going to keep joe
rogan because he generates more money
for us
okay so so this is this is this is the
kind of thing that is happening joe
rogan is not a conservative okay
so it's not about one specific political
ideology it's about government telling
businesses to censor because they can't
do it because the first amendment but if
i can coerce a private business to
censor somebody then that's how they're
going to do it they're going to turn the
screws on the private businesses to
screw over the people okay so that's
where the discrimination is going to
come it's not it and i'm telling you you
don't want my guy in charge either
telling telling business to turn you
down either so it's not one-sided it's
both ways
okay so that's a would you believe
question no you better believe it
because it just happened okay so
okay all right do we
um
thank you real specific question now
well um my question is does that sound
like a political motive to you his
question
does that sound like a political motive
or not so i don't think that that is a
question that's appropriate for me to
answer i'm just here to talk about the
enforceability thank you very much okay
thank you okay
all right i think we've moved this along
i think we thank you we beat this horse
pretty dead
so uh
so
representative um
seconded by representative hunt muse
ought to pass on the amendment is there
any discussion on the amendment seeing
none all those okay so we all know who's
voting and who's not voting right okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one two three four five those opposed
you're not on this this subcommittee
okay
and so yes so so able
[Music]
yes
okay
all right so the motion passes five to
four
okay
all right representative patusek second
by representative hunt moves uh ought to
pass as amended any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand
one
five all is opposed
one two three four
okay
all right
and i guess we're all set so we can't
now we're in the public hearing okay
all right so take a brief moment here to
reorganize ourselves
yelling out liars
actually
oh that's just two days
good question
because some idiot keeps
smiling in a different way
some of them closed the daily hearing
right so i just made a new copy making
sure i captured everybody
ocd i track these things
good job
plus i know you you got to watch all
this i can i can feed you to stuff
right
i gotta go to the boys room
okay sir thank you
guys
thank you
oh
foreign
thank you
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
hb 12
10 28 and hear from the prime sponsor
representative yukovic
sorry about the delay
um thank you thank you mr chair no rush
my next bill is at 11 so i have plenty
of time i'm here only for a few minutes
uh thank you for inviting me members of
the committee mr chair
my bill is quite simple just a few lines
this is about health insurance this is
about short-term health insurance
with friends help i found out that the
short-term health insurance in new
hampshire is restricted unlike
in some other states and the short-term
insurance though may not be
comprehensive this is perfect uh
vehicle for people with low-income
people people who are working gig
economy people
who are between jobs in these uncertain
times
who can't afford the multi thousand
dollar premiums per month
and who would enjoy this kind of care or
coverage
while they're looking for something else
or maybe positioning themselves better
that's what my build is about it's
opening up that market to the people who
don't have any insurance right now
we have the fiscal note on the bill
it's all zeros throughout every year
there's no appropriations there are no
expenditures
revenue is undetermined
now the fiscal note states that opening
up lower cost
options to consumers will
um affect the
established companies so by having these
options given to consumers they make it
sound like that's a bad thing to people
who do not have insurance currently but
i don't believe the established
companies will suffer because some of
them already provide these term plans in
other states where they can
and in new hampshire we're looking at
five percent of all granite staters are
uninsured currently
just because they cannot afford anything
better
so
by removing the restrictions that exist
in statute today will provide for better
coverage for our citizens
for example in other states i like in
florida i look in florida they do not
have restrictions such as we do
there are seven providers that provide
term plans in florida in new hampshire
there's only one and they only do six
effectively five months plan
once in florida consumers are
able to purchase a year at a time and
renew three times
now there are there's oversight at the
federal level that affects everybody
else
but it's working in other states and
providers are moving in so i'd like to
do the same in new hampshire
and
i think this is perfect time to look at
these options because with the current
shortages and scheduling issues and
precautions
the few months that the new hampshire
consumers get in these term plans is
really not enough if there's something
serious they need to go back for a
consultation they need to do
some extra
interfacing with providers so the few
months that they get is really nothing
quite useless i would say again we're
looking at five percent of
citizens uninsured at this point
so i'd like to give them
these options because this is new age
this is after the chaos of the last few
years in the medical health fields
i think they need this and i understand
there are bureaucracies that are
sometimes lazy to look at new options
but not all of them the smart ones
already offering these plans and the
smart ones will get the consumers
the from the news pool of people which
is probably close to 100 000 in new
hampshire
so
um
so the these people usually younger
people people in between jobs people of
lower means lower income they don't
require the belts and whistles plans
that
many other companies provide they can go
for something simple and these plans the
term plans would cost less than 100 a
month which is quite affordable to those
who seek it so let's please give them
the option
let's give them the option to enroll to
get insured with the coverage they can
actually afford
so thank you okay
uh
representative weston had a question yes
uh thank you for coming today and thanks
for taking my question you mentioned
some federal oversight and i wonder if
you could clarify what you mean by that
uh yes thank you for the question so
currently
um the federal oversight is renewals
there are three renewals of these plans
allowed
that's what they are thank you
okay thank you
i thought they the
obamacare banned
banned them because they were considered
under insured that their policies were
limited they had caps they had things
and so theoretically
they were illegal
under after under the federal law
uh thank you for the question not today
three renewals are allowed
and again these are 400 a month
well the reason yeah the reason they're
so cheap is some of them were only ten
thousand dollars
over the year
that the whole plan that was the only
thing it would cover a payout maximum
was ten thousand dollars so that was
considered underinsured
so so that that that's why it was
considered
back then yes
thank you there were some changes made
so you know they are allowed and with
three renewals at the federal level that
would be interesting to find out okay
thank you robertson griesen thank you mr
chair
thank you for uh representative for this
uh
do these plans
also cover mental health or should they
because it's not specified in
the wording that you presently have
um thank you for the question
i'm not quite sure if they do
um it's up to the providers when they
come in again like in say florida there
are seven different providers so i'm
sure there are some differences between
them in new hampshire we only have one
currently
and as more more of them will move in
i'm sure they'll provide
what the public is seeking the most
but yeah but mine is a restriction i
don't go into specific coverage
in the ability
none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you okay
um
chair we're calling justin
daniel
in support of the bill
oh donald sorry oh dawn
good morning
yeah you have to turn the push the
button and pull it up close to you
uh good morning mr chair members of the
committee my name is justin o'donnell
from manchester um i have extensive
experience in the insurance industry
it's been my prime field of work for the
past decade in all fields underwriting
plan design plan construction sales and
plan management um from everything from
selling medicare plans to underwriting
specific covert exemptions over the past
two years and i helped representative
yakubovich research this bill and when
he approached me uh looking for
something that we could do to expand the
market one of my biggest concerns was
seeing people that i've been selling
insurance to for the past decade who are
in that bubble
where they make too much money to
qualify for the subsidies to be able to
afford the obamacare plans but not
enough money
to actually be able to afford them out
of pocket while still paying their other
bills and this is that little bubble of
people that five percent of new
hampshire that just do not have
insurance because they have decided
that
the six hundred dollar a month premium
with an eight thousand dollar a year
deductible before they're actually
covered for anything
isn't worth the out-of-pocket expense
for something they might may not need
and it tends to be younger people it
tends to be healthier people people who
could pass a medical underwriting exam
for a short-term plan people who
would like catastrophic coverage in case
something were to happen especially
maybe a car accident because their
primary source of income is uber or
doordash and these gigan economies with
employers that don't provide coverage
for them removing these instruction
restrictions on short-term plans would
only benefit by
allowing people greater access to a
marketplace and to some of the questions
that were asked some of the older plans
with caps they just don't exist anymore
those were true catastrophic plans so
where they would just pay out the event
that something were to happen
similar to life insurance we call them
they still exist and they're still
actually very popular in new hampshire
they were never regulated out we call
them
uh
named sickness or named illness plans
the most popular cancer heart attack and
stroke insurance where if you're
diagnosed with cancer or if you have a
heart attack or a stroke it pays out a
ten thousand dollar lump sum
the point of which is to cover the
deductible on your obamacare plan that
wouldn't pay for it otherwise
so
the
huge increase that we have seen in
regulation over the past
decade with health insurance has just
left people
in these odd positions where with your
you're tethered to
a w2 employment because you can't afford
to be an entrepreneur because you can't
afford to insure yourself and your
family and a lot of young people like
myself are in a position where we can't
afford the health insurance that's on
the marketplace
unless we're tethered to a higher paying
1099 job and are willing to pay the
thousand dollars a month for it whereas
myself i would love to
take a lower paying contract and focus
on building my business and setting
myself up for a future with my family
but if i had to pay the insurance
premiums that lower paying contract
wouldn't pay my mortgage
and
represent representative greeson has a
question
thank you mr and thank you for uh for
your testimony uh
would it be a correct assessment
that this bill would open up the market
to more choices for consumers and to
actually be able to meet their needs
absolutely as representative yakubovic
said in florida there are seven
providers in new hampshire there's one
currently i'm a licensed health
insurance sales agent in all 50 states i
don't sell in new hampshire
it's not worth it because there's no
competitive option to offer my consumers
so when you're the one policy that is
here you don't consider it a viable
product i don't consider it a viable
product because
it's it's very corner case it's a niche
product it's you lose your job you get
the short-term insurance and you have a
new responsibility to hunt for a new job
that's going to give you employer
coverage because you're not allowed to
renew that plan the one available in new
hampshire what this bill does is list
restrictions on the availability of
renewals the insurance companies don't
want to sell in new hampshire with
short-term plans because they can't be
renewed
and if somebody has had short-term
coverage in new hampshire right now
anytime in the past three years they're
ineligible to purchase a new short-term
policy even if it's not a renewal
so there's no incentive for insurance
companies to even enter the market in
new hampshire because they're restricted
from offering consumers the ability to
retain their products
it's sort of an oxymoron if it's
if it's short-term shouldn't it be
non-renewal i mean isn't that the whole
point non-renewal because if it's
if you can keep renewing it then it
wouldn't be a short-term policy would it
now so we look at short-term and on the
sales side of insurance a little bit
differently than people might look at it
from a bureaucratic or legislative side
where short term to us is the term of
the policy before it resets
and whether six months or one year as
opposed to an indefinite period as long
as you're employed
the difference between the obamacare
plans and the short-term plans
is the medical underwriting and whether
or not they cover pre-existing
conditions there was a question about
mental health again that does vary plan
to plan not every plan will cover
preventative mental health some will
some won't and that will be reflected in
their market price premiums and their
deductibles that those plans have but
usually short-term plans do have medical
underwriting these would not be a
one-size-fits-all approach to everybody
this would not be a good plan for a lot
of people
but having the option out there for the
people who it would be a good choice for
is a good thing in my opinion
would you just hit the magic word
underwriting
obamacare banned underwriting
we actually
banned underwriting in this state only
for long-term credible coverage and the
restrictions and definitions on what is
credible coverage have been changed
under the trump administration
the penalties for not having credible
coverage moved
no i'm saying that
the state of new hampshire actually
banned medical underwriting
for group health insurance this wouldn't
be group health insurance this would be
an individual
we experimented with
repealing
that ban for individuals
for a brief period of time
but then we unilaterally reversed that
because the premiums
to remove the medical underwriting was
through the roof
so by removing medical underwriting
right
you would put the premiums to the roof
because you would be de facto creating
only a single large group where the
insurance company would have to share
every ensure every individual as part of
a group and assume
the worst case statistics guaranteed
issue no
assuming there's not guaranteed issue
assuming that
medical under in other words the whole
reason why new hampshire plan is
medically underwritten the premiums go
down because the insurance company is
allowed to assess the risk
exactly so his plans these short-term
plans would not be a would not be a good
fit as i'm saying for somebody who has
medical issues the target of these
short-term plans is younger healthier
people who might work in a gig economy
who don't have a need for comprehensive
coverage but want coverage that's
cheaper and more affordable for them in
the event something does happen these
plans are ideal for covering a sickness
that comes up or an accident that
happens and in fact the word health
insurance doesn't actually appear in
most state laws we call it accident and
sickness insurance correct
okay
all right thank you very much for your
testimony
the chair will call greg moore from
americans for prosperity who is in
support of the bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee always a pleasure to come
before the house commerce committee
always a pleasure to see you greg thank
you uh
for the record my name is greg moore i'm
the state director for americans for
prosperity here in new hampshire and we
come to testify in support of house bill
fundamentally uh it's a different space
for us we don't usually play in the the
the carrier space or the insurance base
our focus in terms of reducing health
care costs and i know that everybody on
this committee has a an interest in
trying to reduce healthcare costs we're
more focused on increasing increa
increasing the supply of providers and
creating more competition in the
provider space more than an insurance
base but
um
the the sponsor uh
reached out
maybe even badgered uh
us
to take a look at this particular piece
of legislation so he did and i went back
and i looked at the the history
the initial
genesis of
rsa4155 roman 3 actually dates back to
senate bill 30
which is from 1995.
um
it's a very thick piece of legislation
that looks like it
apparently came out of a out of a
study committee but uh senate bill 30 is
where the genesis of this this
particular provision came into law now
the
the archives don't go back that far
sadly so i don't know
about the same time that congress was
discussing uh what ultimately ended up
becoming hipaa and for those of for
those folks
hipaa doesn't just include medical
privacy a lot of hipaa is about
insurance regulation so it seems like
there are a lot of concurrent issues
with hipaa that are included in uh
in in san diego 30.
that initial iteration allowed for up to
six months and no renewals so it was
just six months and no renewals on that
that was changed twice at the request of
the department of insurance um
in
2001 we have house bill 394 and that
allowed for one renewal
so two such policies
within within a 12-month period but then
you'd have to take a break before
getting another one
that changed in 2009 with house bill uh
237 hospital 237 has the existing lane i
was
for
540 days which essentially is 18 months
out of
out of any two-year period so
the department of insurance has
basically
pushed out the the duration of these
types of plans
and
ultimately there has been nothing since
then largely because a lot of the
individual market has been subsumed
thanks to the affordable care act uh as
a federal priority and to be fair the
affordable care act is a great deal if
you're between 138 and 200 percent of
federal property level and it's a good
deal if you're between 200 and 250
percent of the federal property property
level and then it sort of progressively
becomes less and less a good deal until
you hit 400 when the subsidies just drop
off and you have to pay the full freight
uh that's fine uh
percent of the federal poverty level
is
for an individual is fifty four thousand
three hundred and sixty dollars
the catch is is that here in new
hampshire the average
weekly wage is thirteen hundred and
forty five dollars which annualizes
sixty nine thousand nine hundred and
forty dollars or five hundred and
fifteen percent of the federal property
level which means that the average job
in new hampshire
is putting you in a position where as an
individual anyway obviously you have you
can have a if you have a family your 400
fpl goes up but as an individual you are
now outside of getting any subsidies uh
within the individual marketplace
and i think there are a lot of people
who are transitioning out of more
traditional jobs into
gig economy jobs who might be making the
average wage for whom this this is a
problem and so i spent a little time
went on the
the new hampshire marketplace which some
people
still colloquially referred to as the
obamacare exchange but in the individual
marketplace went in plugged in some
numbers
put in i put in a 45 year old male
non-smoker
what did i get for a silver plan that's
349 a month that's your that would be
your your premium
then they went over to ehealth to check
the one provider of uh short-term health
insurance in new hampshire and plugged
in the same number
came in at
193 dollars a month which is 45 percent
less
obviously uh that's a savings of you
know if you had it annualized it would
be uh
1876 dollars a month
and so
the
ability for folks particularly young
people who
no longer have access to
no longer have access to employer
insurance and frankly are looking at
what's available as a silver plan in the
in the
insurance the new hampshire marketplace
these this might create an opportunity
for them and so from our perspective as
a deregulatory approach giving people
another option and i'll grant you it's
not the same policy it's not apples to
apples we're not talking they're
different types of plans
and
i think but i think that the language
here is is a positive deregulatory step
um we think it's a good idea to move
forward and it's it's a good idea to
provide some option for some people
it's but i'll i'll be the first person
person to admit i've i went through the
legislative history looking at the two
the two pieces of 2001 and 2009. the
good news is those archives are
available those calendars are available
so you can read the blurb you can read
the minutes
and
and the historical complaint is that uh
consumers don't know what they're
getting and and
that's been the complaint that they
don't know what they're getting and i i
think the legislation is a positive but
i would i would say that we've certainly
from the standpoint of uh from the
standpoint of people purchasing and now
when you're buying these types of plans
a lot of them buy them via the internet
which just adds one more level of
obscurity i think that that putting
something in there uh in addition to
this about
maybe giving the department of insurance
uh some authority on it under 541a to
require some disclosures uh
probably wouldn't be a bad idea
generally but uh if and if you decide to
move forward favorably on this type of
plan it would be a definitely a positive
step because um it used to be if you
wanted to go buy a short-term policy you
probably had to call a company directly
or go through an agent who might explain
some of the limitations of a plan like
this right now there are none so that
might be something that
the committee wants to consider but we
do support the bill and i'd be happy to
take any questions
yes representative johnson
thank you for taking my question so this
just so i make sure i understand it this
would cover it as an example
um a college student coming out of
college they're coming off their parents
plan at 26
there 25 26 i can't remember exact
cutoff but they haven't fully found a
job that
offers insurance yet this could cover
them
in that short term
i would say that depends on a case by
case basis if you are somebody who is
not making a lot of money i wouldn't go
this route i think that going but if
they had like a small job but they
weren't in their career right if per se
if they had a job where they were making
the average new hampshire wage and
they're outside of that 400 percent and
maybe even you know once you get outside
of like 300 percent it you know like i
said progressively the the subsidies
drop off pretty quickly this might be an
option that would be a good choice for
someone like that
thank you okay thank you very much
uh chair we'll call on michelle heaton
from the insurance department because
i guess tyler had to go somewhere else
yeah i think he's in the senate
what they're more important than us
hello my name is michelle heaton i'm the
health law and policy legal counsel at
the insurance department you just pulled
the mic a little bit closer
thanks
is this better yeah
so the insurance department does not
have a formal position on this bill
we're just here for really informational
purposes
and one of the concerns we do have with
this bill is that
the effect that's intended is not what's
going to be accomplished by this bill
and part of that reason is because the
way short-term limited duration policies
are defined at the federal level would
preclude us from doing too much to
deregulate it at a state level
these are largely unregulated products
but we do regulate them
in new hampshire they are subject to
insurance laws and there are specific
insurance rules for short-term limited
duration policies as well as ancillary
health policies which are different than
major medical and i know there was some
mention of them earlier
excuse me
consumers that usually
buy these
it is a stop gap measure and there are
that's the reason why it is for a
limited duration
they do allow pre-existing conditions
and they are not guaranteed renewable so
they're not subject to the same
requirements as typical major medical
insurance
nationally there are reports that many
consumers don't really understand what
they're purchasing when they get these
types of products and that they are
misled into thinking that it covers more
than what a traditional major med policy
would cover
there's also the concern that short-term
policies may appeal to younger healthier
people and those people are being pulled
from the major medical insurance market
which could cause
an increase in premium for major med
products
i'm happy to answer any questions
i was wondering when you're going to get
around to talking about adverse
selection
okay
all right uh any questions yes
representative abel
yes thank you thank you very much um and
thank you for for testifying
is it accurate to
describe these kinds of policies as
catastrophic coverage they are different
than catastrophic coverage catastrophic
coverage has different requirements and
they are subject to certain aca
requirements whereas short-term limited
duration the way they're defined on the
federal level specifically exempts them
from the aca requirements
representative greeson
thank you ann thank you for your
testimony the recommendation that came
just a moment ago
to uh require the insurance company to
provide disclosures would would that be
because you had said something about
people
not necessarily knowing what they're
buying
and therefore they could cause them some
troubles would that be the solution uh
these disclosures or or or how would
what is it that was recommended versus
how do we solve the problem of people
not necessarily understanding
what they're getting
it's a harder problem to solve than you
would think
under
we currently do have filing requirements
and rules that regulate short-term
limited duration policies as well as
ancillary health policies and the
ancillary health for those who may not
be familiar would be like your hospital
only
coverage for specific disease
all of our rules do require a lot of
these very specific disclosures and you
know embold that this is not major
medical coverage
yet despite our efforts to try to put in
these regulations and to
help educate consumers on this it's a
constant problem throughout the country
that a lot of these ancillary health
products are marketed in a way that
misleads people into thinking they're
buying major med coverage and it's
something that not only our department
but all insurance departments across the
country are constantly trying to figure
out ways to make it clearer
for the question may inquire thank you
so would you if we were to
amend this bill to try to tackle that
problem would you be able to assist us
with language
uh that
i guess what i'm getting at is we want
people to understand what they're buying
but how many people buy all kinds of
things not necessarily knowing exactly
what they're buying like say automobile
insurance for example
uh
you know
is there is there a recommendation of
language could you provide language that
would work from an enforcement
standpoint from the consumer protection
standpoint and from the business that
wants to sell the product standpoint
yeah we would be happy this is something
that we could do yeah and i believe we
do have rules already on that so we
could use this similar type of language
okay any other questions see none thank
you very much for your testimony
okay
i have
three more cards here all in opposition
holly stevens from
nami new hampshire
good morning
good morning i had to just check to make
sure it still was morning
chairman and members of the committee my
name is holly stevens and i'm the
director of public policy for nami new
hampshire the national the national
alliance on mental illness
nami new hampshire is a non-profit
grassroots organization whose mission is
to improve the lives
of all people impacted by mental illness
and suicide through support education
and advocacy
on behalf of nami new hampshire i'm here
today to oppose
house bill 1028
as you've heard under current new
hampshire law there is a restriction on
these short-term
limited duration plans
that they can be no more than six months
and there's restrictions on
you know how many times they can be
renewed and those are in place for a
good reason
especially for people with mental health
conditions having access to affordable
comprehensive
health insurance is critical for getting
the mental health care they need
the aca
as we know
set forth a lot of provisions that these
plans do not have to follow
one of them is the essential health
benefits
so they don't have to cover mental
health or substance use disorder
services they don't have to cover
prescriptions
as a matter of fact there was a survey
done
of a lot of these plans throughout the
country and at the time there were two
providers in new hampshire neither one
of them
covered prescriptions
these short-term plans can reject
applicants based on their mental health
conditions
they can charge people with mental
health conditions more than they charge
people without mental health conditions
they can exclude because exclude them
from coverage because they have a
pre-existing mental health condition
again they don't have to cover the
services at all
and
one of the things that the sponsor had
mentioned that sometimes with these
plans
somebody during that first initial six
months will become sick
and that six months doesn't allow them
time to follow up with their care
ongoing well guess what
once you get sick you have a
pre-existing condition
and they do not have to renew your
policy
so
you know all of a sudden you actually
have an illness that needs coverage
and at the end of that six months term
they say see you later
go find a major medical plan uh that
falls under the aca we're not gonna
renew your coverage for you
so
you know they've just paid for six
months for a plan
and then
all of a sudden they don't get to follow
up with those providers they have to
find a new plan so that's something that
should be considered by this committee
um
there was a national study done that
showed that 50
of these plans across the country did
not cover mental health and sud services
which is huge
and many as you've heard many of them
are sold using deceptive tactics and
i've included some footnotes in my
testimony for the sources of those
information you can certainly go and
look up those reports and i've also
included a
i think it's a four-page report
giving some information on these
short-term plans
that can be found on the nami national
website
these plans are
of particular
interest to younger individuals because
they are cheaper and they think okay
it's cheaper
you know i'm going to sign up for this
plan not realizing that
they're not getting what they think
they're getting
and the other thing that we know about
mental illness is that
symptoms for major mental illnesses
often occur in early adulthood
when
you know kids are in college when
they're just leaving college
or i should say young adults they're not
kids at that point but these are the the
individuals that these
plans are targeted at
and if they buy one of these plans and
then have
their first episode of psychosis
say
and that plan doesn't cover any mental
health treatment
they've just played for a plan that they
have
there's nothing they it gives them
nothing in return and you're talking
about potentially
being hospitalized
for
a significant period of time
needing ongoing medications and needing
ongoing treatment
that the plan they just paid for
is not going to cover
um
so they're going to have to end up
getting another plan anyway
so you know in short these plans you
know really fail to provide what they
seem to provide on the surface
and i think it really should hit home
that if you get sick in that first six
months there's a good chance you're not
going to be able to renew anyway
because of the nature of the the plan so
with that i just urge the committee to
really seriously think about this
um and
vote itl on this bill
representative johnson has a question
so my question thank you for taking my
question
trying to figure out the right way to
word this so it doesn't come out
incorrectly
if
we open this up so that insurance
providers can offer this to
these individuals
with knowing that they need to explain
off doesn't that give the consumers a
chance to look at all their options and
it's isn't it the consumers
who need to do their due diligence to
make sure what they're asking for a plan
is being offered and if they don't like
what they're being offered they don't
have to choose that plan aren't we
restricting the consumers to make their
own choice
yeah thank you for the question
the regulations that new hampshire put
in place many years ago
were put in place because
you know
this committee and others like them felt
that individuals needed to be protected
the house commerce and consumer affairs
committee and consumer affairs is a part
of the name
of this committee
you know really is here to help
protect consumers there's reasons that
we have consumer protection laws
and there are times when due to
the way that things are marketed
i i will tell you you know prior to
coming to nami new hampshire i was the
health policy
coordinator at new futures for five
years
and i don't know how many conversations
i had with individuals
who have no idea how their health plans
work whether their employers sponsored
plans self-insured plans
so i mean i think that there are times
that products are very very confusing
and
it's really difficult to educate
yourself about what you're getting and
you know young people
think that they're not going to get sick
they think they're healthy
and so i would just say that you know
part of this committee's job is to also
look at protecting those folks too
representative terry
thank you
i believe that i heard from one of the
previous uh speakers
that there either are uh
no companies or only one company that
provides
short-term policies
uh
so what what's the situation for the
folks that you're talking about right
now when there's only
one well it's not even an option because
you have to have more than one to have
an option when you only got one
and how would this bill be any worse
than the situation that exists right now
thank you for the question
there is only one right now but as you
heard the reason there's only one right
now is because
new hampshire has tight restrictions on
these policies you lift those
restrictions and you could have numerous
companies coming into this state
and
these will not be targeted just at that
five percent of individuals who do not
currently have insurance
there is nothing in this bill that says
you know if you are below 400 percent of
the federal poverty level
and therefore
are covered
have have the ability to get subsidies
on the aca plan
um
you know you can't
get a short-term plan instead there's
nothing that's in there that says that
there's nothing in there that says if
you were afforded you know health care
under your employer
that um and a lot of employers do allow
you to turn down their insurance
that wouldn't say that you know you
can't turn down that coverage
and get one of these plans and get a
stipend from your from your employer
so
again i mean if you're only looking at
that five percent versus nothing versus
this
that's one thing but that's not what
you're looking at you're looking at a
hundred percent of new hampshire
residents being able to buy one of those
plans
for the question main query
so
how
given that i believe that one of the
states that was cited was florida with
seven
uh providers under their their law
i i don't know whether you're familiar
with the situation
in florida i guess i'm asking that
or an another state where
the there are multiple
carriers that are in the market
with respect to the concerns that you're
raising for the particular group of
people with the mental health issues
are they are they worse off or better
off
with those
types of policies than than the existing
situation in new hampshire
or are you saying that the existing
state
of affairs here in new hampshire is
actually better for folks with mental
health issues and that under this bill
or
in other states that have options that
those folks are worse off
i don't have any information about other
states um
but
you know knowing that these plans a lot
of times don't even cover
the services that those folks would need
they would be paying a monthly premium
premium and i believe that um it was
cited that they're around two hundred
dollars a month so if you're paying
you know 200 a month for something that
you can't even use i would say that
you're in a worse position
so so excuse me just one file so are you
suggesting that we'd be going from good
to bad for your folks or bad to worse
i don't know the answer to that question
so you don't know whether this bill
you've spoken against the bill yes so is
it worse
it's absolutely going to be worse i mean
i don't know that we're good that's the
the caveat bad
bad currently and it'll be worse under
this bill or it's good and it's going to
be drastically worse i don't
represent if i don't have the numbers of
how many individuals with mental illness
young folks currently are uninsured but
i can certainly try to find that out
uninsured in new hampshire for you
if that would be helpful
yes thank you okay
any other questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony
jake berry from new futures
right
good morning mr chairman honorable
members of the committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
at new futures as many of you know new
future is a non-partisan nonprofit
health policy and advocacy organization
we've been working for a number of years
to increase access to quality affordable
health care in this state
i don't want to repeat too much of what
has been said already this morning but i
do want to emphasize new futures strong
opposition to this bill
the federal protections that have been
so spoken about repeatedly
that were put in place by the affordable
care act they're a real thing they've
really gone far to increase access to
mental health as holly just mentioned to
substance use treatment to the other
essential health benefits including
emergency care maternity care child
birth care so on and so forth uh
under this bill short term health plans
aren't required to cover any of this as
you have heard and in fact many of them
do not
a
2018 study that i was looking at from
the kaiser family foundation found that
43 percent of short-term health plans
across the country cover
mental health uh i'm sorry do not cover
mental health 62 do not cover substance
use treatment and not a single plan
covered maternity care i will note that
these are some benefits that are most
essential to the
or that are supremely essential to the
younger population that uh that was
mentioned earlier as a
particular target for these plans
so essentially these plans
have lesser coverage
they lead to higher out-of-pocket costs
for consumers
decreased access to care for consumers
greater uncompensated care which as
we've seen in your past to higher health
care across all across the spectrum and
generally lead to poorer health outcomes
i would say that unlike our current
plans
these plans are not not only not
comprehensive in many cases they're
predatory
and so i i would strongly uh uh urge you
to uh oppose this bill vote this bill
itl
and i'm happy to take questions
predatory
why are they predatory it's a and it's a
strong word i should say but i think
that they um
many of them again uh you know we've
talked about their their marketing
practices and their sort of lack of
transparency around the benefits that
they provide i think that they charge
a you know monthly premiums to people
knowing that these people are not aware
of the benefits that they will or will
not be receiving
okay
uh we do have a question representative
mclaren um are you familiar with a
company called combined
i'm not no no sir no okay thank you sure
good thank you very much
got one more card left
uh nancy vaughn
american heart association
in opposition to the bill
good morning chairman hunt members of
the committee for the record i am nancy
vaughn government relations director for
the american heart association new
hampshire
and
the american heart association is the
nation's oldest and largest voluntary
organization dedicated to improving the
cardiovascular health of all americans
and we've worked diligently for many
years to support and advance strong
public health policies in addition to
providing critical tools and information
health care providers patients and
families to treat heart disease and
stroke
the american heart association
appreciates this opportunity
to be able to offer comments in
opposition to house bill 1028
primarily around our concerns on the
lack of consumer protections
short-term limited duration plans
originally meant to be you know coverage
for gaps such as in between jobs or
young adults coming off their parents
insurance plan
but only for those individuals who do
not have pre-existing conditions
short-term plans as
others have said provide the same cut do
not provide the same coverage that
people have come to expect traditional
health insurance
and if these plans are allowed to be
sold in new hampshire for longer time
periods with unlimited renewals an
individual's health status could change
and they could end up facing
considerable financial risk
from
unexpected
illness
and the the cost of health care services
that would not be
covered by by the plan
while short-term limited duration plans
can offer cheaper premiums for consumers
they are not required to adhere to
important standards including coverage
of state mandated health benefits age
and gender rating prohibitions on
discriminating against people with
pre-existing conditions the annual
out-of-pocket maximums
nor the prohibitions on annual and
lifetime coverage limits
limiting the duration and renewability
of short-term plans as the state
currently does allows a market for the
product but only as a temporary coverage
options limits on short-term plans can
also make it more obvious to consumers
shopping for coverage that these are a
different type of insurance
product intended only for temporary
coverage
thank you for your consideration of the
american heart association's comments
and i urge the committee to vote
inexpedient to legislate on this bill
all right thank you very much thank you
very much for your time okay having no
more cards
uh the blue sheets i've got
paula rogers and peter bragnon are
anthem and harvard pilgrim in opposition
and on the mid overnight
postings we have seven support and 12
opposed
and will that i will close the public
hearing on 10 28.
uh
um
okay we'll open up the public hearing
representative
thank you mr chairman
and members of commerce
um i'm betty gay and i represent salem
i'm very concerned about people who got
bad reactions to vaccines
even though they're in the
small percentage if it happens to them
it's a hundred percent
and
if you're interested if you haven't seen
it c19vaxreactionsplural.com
is a place that you can read about these
very wide
very different kind of responses that
some people's bodies have done
and i was horrified to find out that
if you get a reaction
to a
a treatment
like a vaccine is a treatment
if you get a bad reaction to one that
does not have full-fledged fda approval
and all you know so far
excuse me all
all vaccines except for one
that we don't even have
uh
were released under emergency
authorization
so under current law if you have
something that if you have any kind of
treatment that is not
100 percent covered by fda
your insurance company is not obligated
to cover the treatment for that
so i thought it was going to be just
really simple and unfortunately the to
me this bill looks has almost like a
double negative in it but it gets
scrambled by legislative services yes so
let's just stick to what your intent is
and don't worry about the wording okay
we'll figure that out thank you you can
fix it
um oh and then right now there's a hard
there's a glitch there's a bug in the
rsa look up on our website
so but they're working on it
okay so if you can see on the bill the
coverage the old words are covered for
experimental or investigational drugs or
really it's in the list of what is not
covered by insurance so they modified it
to add besides experimental or
investigational drugs vaccines devices
medications are the reactions to them
the important thing is or the reactions
to them
if they're not approved by the fda
but
what it's saying
that has been
unless they're authorized by emergency
use so that just adds in that it's
emergency authorization would cover
those reactions too
and so they apparently was in two
different rsa so it's almost the same
wording in both
good so hopefully this is the simplest
bill you have to look at today so simply
that that if uh if you did have an
adverse
effect you don't want the insurance
companies to
not cover it simply because it was not
uh officially approved it will be
it's actually it's interesting because
it's the first paragraph in the off
label prescription and i was around when
we passed that statute
which was that you're if you were you
know
using a medication for something that it
was not originally designed for so
and you had a bad reaction and you had
well in that case you know you it would
be covered the insurance companies would
still cover it so all you want to do is
make sure insurance companies cover you
regardless
uh well excuse me they're the regard it
had to be if you had to had the
emergency use approved by the fda if it
did then you want whatever the
the symptoms
be covered by the insurance company
thank you for your wording
okay
any questions from the committee
uh seeing none everybody got it thank
you
okay uh also i believe is the co-sponsor
j.j
bernardi
good morning jd
good morning chairman hunt good morning
commerce committee
thank you for this opportunity to
support
this
legislation i'm j.d bernardi rockingham
southampton kensington and east kingston
um
i support this uh this legislation
because there's been a very strong push
for folks to use the the covid vaccines
yet they were approved with emergency
use authorizations only
and until
late fall
pfizer
finally got full approval but only for
adults
and last week modernist vaccine got
approval
again only for adults
so
emergency youth authorization
still stands for
children and and younger adults and if
you look at the vares database that's
the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
the number of adverse events for these
vaccines are substantially higher than
traditional vaccines
so
young men are experiencing myocarditis
young women are experiencing fertility
problems
and yet because
of the way the insurance rules are
written
emergency use authorization
products are not covered by their
insurance and so what we want to do is
change that circumstance
good representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um i'd like you to um
cite the information regarding um women
having problems with fertility and men
with
myocarditis it's in the vares database
v-a-e-r-s
federal database you can check those
numbers i didn't bring those numbers
with me today
well let's just take infertility uh
since we now have that mandate in new
hampshire
um
is there any report where an insurance
company would not cover the infertility
coverage because
they said it was due to
this
a vaccine
i mean
i i can't give you any particular
citation i just i'm aware of the fact
that the database is suggesting that
uh
that the there was a potential bad
outcome that there's a potential for
over accumulation
of the vaccine causing uh infertility
problems got it okay
any other questions representative
johnson
um
so the department of defense maintains
its own
vaccine database does it not yes it does
um and this is a more robust in-depth
collection of data
more robust in that the
only people that can enter data into the
dod
database are physicians as opposed as
opposed to the vares database you can
have public
entry of data correct
according to the dod's database there
has been a hundred percent a thousand
percent increase in neurological
neurological issues
and 300
percent increase in miscarriages and
several other reactions post vaccine
so my question
is are all these data points just
anti-vaxxed fairy tales or i mean are
these
real numbers that they're showing in
this data
they're real numbers in the dod database
and and
just to add to that
this database was put together uh it's
been going for several years
so you look at the 2020 numbers when
when uh the
covid prior to covid then you can look
at 2021 when we had covid here but no
vaccines available and then you can look
at
the current data and and you see what
you're suggesting is or what the
database is saying is that
clearly there has been a
serious increase in the number of a
broad spectrum of adverse events
associated with the vaccine that's the
only real change in
what's going on with these young folks
in the military it's a you know a young
healthy population why are we seeing
this tremendous change and and
the um
the medical opinion is it's being driven
by the vaccine
thank you for your answer thank you very
much for your oh representative
burroughs
thank you for taking my question can you
cite any studies um done by um
any studies done by credible agencies to
support the the correlation between the
vaccines and
these incidents and and problems
i i would suggest that the dod database
is the best study that you have you have
you have
young
healthy folks
in the military
and
they're they're being followed their
entire military career and that that is
the best data that we have on on this
right now
follow up
for the question you mean car um
so again in the database are there just
numbers let's say
what what does the database tell you
does it tell you that there are 3 000
women with fertility problems uh after
having the vaccine
it tell it gives you an incidence rates
of various
uh conditions
they may not be called adverse events i
mean you heard uh representative johnson
say all right neurological problems okay
that that that so what you see is
a
a increase in all these different areas
of of
medical problems
and
and you then you have to say what caused
this what changed
from last year
and the year before what's what is
different that we haven't had before now
maybe there's another medical
explanation but the only credible
explanation that's been posited today is
these are effects of the vaccine
quick follow-up okay just real quick um
you know i would would you believe that
i think that
more data
to to find out where these numbers are
coming from would be really important
before we decide that there is a cause
and an effect kind of thing with the
vaccine i think we're making assumptions
more data is always helpful
okay great thank you very much for your
testimony
oh you take another question
representative
yeah uh i'm just looking on the ver's
website
site and um are you familiar with
this paragraph which
begins with but with newfound attention
on theirs this crucial public health
system which anyone can access is ripe
for abuse
misuse and plain misunderstanding have
you read that on that website
yes that's why i made the comment that
the the the distinction between the
theirs database and the dod database is
the vera's database
you do not have to be a physician to
have filed the adverse event claim
and hence that that causes that
statement to be part of the public
notice with respect to that database
whereas the dod database that
representative johnson uh
as
has brought to the uh our attention is
only
managed by
physicians in the military and therefore
does not contain that same disclaimer
yeah so actually uh representative
creation just reminded that he sent out
an email to all of us uh which had a
video clip and he told us to watch
part of it that four hour the four hour
mark which i did do which it directly
addresses this
uh information from the department of
defense
so so you can learn more by watching
that video
thank you
all right thank you
representative terry and is it is it not
also true that
uh the vares database
uh would capture
potentially uh reports from the entire
population of the united states whereas
the dod
universe is much smaller
therefore a figure
of 82 000 and change in 2020 to
836 thousand
or 863 000 in 2021
is an enormous number in that smaller
universe am i correct in that
you are spot on thank you
okay great thank you very much for your
testimony
uh represent oh no it's good michelle
eaton from the insurance department
takes no position
hello again i'm michelle heaton the
health law and policy legal counsel from
the insurance department um as i said
before we're we don't take a position on
this but we're really here for
informational purposes and when we first
looked at the bill we weren't really
sure what it was trying to accomplish
but now i understand it's because of the
way legislative services put it in um
which makes a little bit more sense um
but there are a couple things in here
that i just wanted to clarify um
experimental investigational drugs are
it's a different process and different
classification than emergency use drugs
so i just want to point that out also i
don't think that
this
this amendment is even necessary
under essential health benefits insurers
would have to cover any medically
necessary treatment whether that came
from um receiving an experimental
vaccine or treatment or not so um
i i don't think that this is necessary
but um
if if we did want to go ahead with it i
would just
suggest cleaning up the language more so
it's a bit clearer as to what we're
trying to accomplish so there's knowing
a big beauty in the future but i'm happy
to take any questions
okay uh did i see your hand yes
representative johnson
hi thank you for taking my question
so i have a kind of a scenario and asked
and to find out if this is true
that i had say someone purchase a has a
health insurance policy they have taken
this experimental shot
and they
die from it
is their insurance
policy
liable to is still
eligible to have they have to pay for
that policy because i've been told there
are people who have put the claims in
for their death
you know they're survivors
and they were saying no because
the death was contributed to the shot
and now they will not cover it because
the shot is still experimental
well
i'm not exactly sure what you're asking
because major medical coverage covers
your medical expenses and if someone
were to die you wouldn't get a death
benefit that from that that would be
like life insurance
that's what i'm talking about the life
insurance i would have to say to you
that unfortunately this bill in the
amendment
the bill as we've seen is addressing
health insurance
a life insurance is a different section
of the statute so if that were true then
we would have to look at a different
section of the statute to ensure that
that
doesn't happen
thank you very much
i have one more caller left and it's
paula minihan and she did not make it
back to the committee room uh and she is
representing new hampshire hospital
association in opposition to the bill
and she will let you know get uh send
her written testimony
and
did i just get another card
i hate that
okay uh and and you signed it you know
you think
okay
why don't you tell us your name because
it looks like stroganoff or something to
me
you have to turn push the little button
so the red light goes on and talk closer
thank you mr chairman ladies and
gentlemen of the committee um
my name is mark stagnone i'm a
chiropractor from londonderry i've been
in practice there for 35 years i'm just
going to take two minutes
because i actually do have before me a
study that you may find interesting in
this topic i'm not from totally familiar
with the language in this bill but i
will i'll simply share with you a study
from the american heart association it
is abstract number one zero seven one
two
and it came out in november
it is entitled
mrna coveted vaccines dramatically
increase
endothelial inflammation markers
and acs risk as measured by the pulse
cardiac test
colon
warning
acs stands for acute coronary syndrome
and i will just read you the last two
lines of this report
we conclude that the mrna facts
dramatically increase inflammation on
the endothelium and t cell infiltration
of cardiac muscle and may account for
the observations of increased thrombosis
cardiomyopathy and other events
following vaccination
now one side note to this study
three weeks later i went to share it
with my colleague representative
lundgren
and the title was changed
and the paragraph i just read to you was
changed and modified and all of the
language was subdued the results were
the same
and the risk factor for an acute
coronary syndrome went from 11 to 25
in a test population that they had
followed for eight years 506
patients that were in this ongoing study
where they met with them every three to
six months they did all the lab work to
measure their their risk of a cardiac
event
and then when they started getting their
shots they continued the program and
these were the observations they made
as the individuals came in post
vaccination
obviously there's more study on their
behalf to do
but given what i was hearing i thought
you might be interested in this
conversation so not that i'm a physician
so i don't know too much about that but
cardiac's one word to me but i do know
isn't this the reason why the johnson
johnson was suspended for a period of
time
well mr chairman i'm i i'm not certain
as to the specifics i think that's
possible the interesting thing here was
it's that it's the
mrna vaccine i think that the j j was a
different
vehicle by which that that one worked
okay
representative bartlett has a question
thanks very much mr chair um can you
tell me what that has to do with this
bill that we're looking at
well uh i'm i'm not terribly familiar
with the bill but i heard the the
gentleman that was up here questioned
earlier that there was the question
about
any solid studies or something to that
effect and i i just thought this study
would be one that might fit into
the topic that you're discussing
and
and i appreciate the the chairman's
ability to let me come up here and share
it well it's very fortuitous that you
did because now paula minnihan is here
so she can't testify
any more ques
he's okay liverpool
burroughs so that study was there any
data to show a correlation between the
participants and pre-existing heart
problems
well from what i read in the experiment
this is why they followed these patients
for the length of time that they did is
that they obviously were
at some level of risk that they were
trying to assess and i can't tell you if
11 to 25 percent is dramatic
it's more than double we can do that
math pretty simply
i don't know how that fits into the word
of cardiology it's certainly not my
specialty
i did feel that it was interesting that
they felt it necessary to issue a
warning
thank you mr chairman
okay great thank you
and now paula
you get the last word on this one
oh what did i do with it oh here it is
and it is still morning good morning
mr chairman sorry it was delayed
downstairs
my name is paula minihan senior vice
president state government relations
with the new hampshire hospital
association representing all our
hospitals we are opposed to house bill
1162 i did not hear
the sponsor introduce the bill so and i
was honestly a little confused in
reading it um
so so the consensus we know what she's
intended to do which is simply that
if it was one of these emergency
vaccines
that the insurance companies would cover
it
if it was under emergency use
authorization if it is if it is that
situation then the insurance companies
must cover it
okay that was the intent
okay
um
i don't know that this bill does that
though well we can we'll the committee
will have that responsibility just to
unwind that
situation okay
so again um we were confused
in reading it
because it implied that the bill would
prohibit insurers from excluding
coverage for any vaccines devices or
medication that has been authorized for
emergency use by the
u.s
food and drug administration however
if you read the statute that's being
amended in its entirety this bill would
in fact allow for the insurer to not
cover
those vaccines um not approved by the
fda and again i think the wording is a
little
challenging because
the fda these if we're talking about
covet vaccines and they're under
emergency use authorization not
under um they're not considered
experimental
so we do not
want
or believe that the insurers should and
i don't think they are so i question the
need of this bill
that we do not want them to deny
vaccinations that have been approved
under emergency use authorization
so that's why we do not support any
limitations of insurance coverage and
again i don't believe in sure i i
believe insurance companies are covering
them so i am not worried about that i
just don't
understand what we need why we would
need this bill so i think um that was
our concern so thank you so uh again the
question i would request for view from
your associate members if you could send
out a bulletin and see if they have any
evidence that an insurance company did
not cover
a symptom
a bad outcome from having to take the
quote-unquote experimental vaccine
okay so the question is i should check
any insurance company refused any if
there was a symptom related to a covet
vaccine vaccination i'm going to start
on the assumption that you of course you
covered it and took care of them yes
that was that patient was there that's
right so i just want to know whether
there was any any any
issue with insurance had any problems
did you guys have anything i will
research that right and get back to you
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
say none thank you very much paul
okay now up before i close the public
hearing i gotta read my blue list
okay so um representative gabe bernini
oh this is engowed um all in support
and from the uh overnight posting
we had
52 people in support and five opposed
that now i will close the public hearing
okay and we're ready
12.45
you ready
okay we'll open up the public hearing
house bill
1245 and hear from the prime sponsor
representative london
good morning rebels in london
thank you mr chair and uh fine committee
for allowing us to talk on house bill
1245. i'll be very brief because i know
what it's like to be sitting there for
hours on end
um
basically this bill uh has to do with
reduction of co-pays
for chiropractors
and also
reducing our
from specialists to a primary care
provider
the copays
reduction make it much more accessible
for patients
yeah just make it closer i'm sorry
believe it or not we're actually
translating your words
oh so
well i should speak in a foreign
language
that would not translate well
anyway
what we find is that p patients come in
a primary for for pain relief
and
we find that by our treatments we're
reducing costs
with insurance companies
due to avoiding any
opioids
uh this bill will be no increase to
insurance costs
and
i just have a couple other things uh
90 percent of
the literature that i've seen showed
cost savings which improved patient
satisfaction lower opioid use among
patients with first-line access to
compute
chiropractors
chiropractors are not specialists and
we'd like to be taken out of that
category to make it
allowable for us to reduce our co-pays
our co-pays right now run from 40 to 60
uh pcp uh runs from say 10 10 to 20 it
makes it the access to our care that
much easier um i'll be happy to try to
answer any questions i know i have three
other people in back of me that want to
speak so i just don't want to spend any
more time
uh representative bartlett has a
question thanks very much mr chair um
you keep saying we so i'm wondering are
you a chiropractor yes i am okay thank
you so much representative yeah david
longrin representative uh i represent uh
ham 5 londonderry
i've been a chiropractor for 45 years i
know i don't look that old
[Laughter]
thanks very much it was just i just
wanted to be thank you
representative burroughs
yeah and this may be a question for
chairman hunt and i generally don't i
really don't know the answer to this has
the legislature ever been responsible
for setting co-payment rates
uh
well yeah yeah sure yes
co-pays and deductibles
i would say the only the only
chiropractor bill i remember in the past
was um that that if the company was to
cover it they'd had to give you 12
visits a year and and
i and and much of that was a health
insurance mandate that that
the chair generally just never supports
mandates
uh she voted against that one and sure
enough there was in carriers
that stopped covering chiropractic
altogether
because we passed that
legislation so that is a sign that so
there is a potential that if we were to
pass this there there might be less
insurance companies offering
chiropractic coverage
so representative bartlett well mr chair
since you opened the door
may i ask if you have any carriers that
will not
cover chiropractic i haven't had any
thank you i haven't had any but
i will say that
teachers
uh state employees
uh that are covered uh and get the 12
visits a year they
their co-pays run between
five dollars for the teachers ten
dollars for the state employees whereas
the general public
could start at 40 and go to
60. i would say uh as you know that
those two entities are what we call
self-insured erisa plans
under federal law we do not regulate
them and this bill will not affect
correct affect that
situation
okay thank you very much thank you for
chime no problem
okay uh
okay mark
stagnell
mr chairman ladies and gentlemen thank
you once again
uh my name is mark stagnone i am a
chiropractor also in londonderry
uh i've been practicing there for 35
years
and actually for about roughly about
half of my career now we've been trying
to address this particular issue related
to specialist co-pays
over the years and some of our hearings
we've gotten into cost studies cost
shift cost analysis how effective are
you people at you know saving money
that's always been a long convoluted
discussion i will stay away from it
for this purpose of saving time for you
our basic premise on this legislation
is that
we are not specialists
we do not practice like specialists
our mode of care is totally different
we are not reimbursed even remotely
similar to specialists and therefore
when our patients arrive and and we have
to notify them that they have a
specialist co-payment
this is a complete surprise to them
because they are typically in my office
i don't even see the forty dollar
specialist copay it's usually 50 and up
and what happens in those instances is
the patient is bearing the brunt of the
entire cost of their care
and this causes some of them to
not pursue care at all
some of them have to discontinue their
care prematurely
um and and we feel that this is harmful
to
the patient
that it is it is an unfair practice
uh it is implemented in a fashion as
dr representative lundgren just
mentioned
you know our patients that come in that
are municipal employees police fire
state workers
etc generally aren't influenced by this
in fact there are there are thousands of
policies out there that aren't affected
by this
particular
classification
but there is enough of them that we see
particularly in view of the opioid
epidemic now we addressed this
long before the opioid epidemic came to
bear
and in february of
2014 in one of our hearings i held up
this issue
of the union leader which was the first
major headline relative to the opioid
epidemic
and said
as part of our support this is coming
and and we need to make sure that we
have all the tools
which includes access
to people like us that can enter into
the care of these patients and keep them
away from
a pharmaceutically based
decision for their care now what happens
with some of our patients that have
these specialist co-pays
is they end up going to the
pharmaceutical care when they abandon
their chiropractic care because they're
carrying the entire brunt of
their their costs and how this works is
the insurance carrier goes to the
employee they and those of you that are
in small business know this every year
you try to figure out what are we going
to what are we going to buy this year
and you sit down and you say well what's
it got and they come in they saw it has
chiropractic okay that's good my people
like that
and mr chairman there is been a huge
attitude shift relative to the
desirability of chiropractic as a
benefit over the years in my career it
has it has pleasantly blossomed
and so the employer is like oh that's
good yeah chiropractic has got it
and then these policies show up at our
office and we have the
pleasure of notifying these patients so
while you have a specialist co-pay we
have been declared as a specialist under
your policy there's thousands of them
that don't have it but some of these do
come in
and we have to share with the patient
now say well your care is not going to
be covered because your co-pays up here
and our mac which is called your maximum
allowable charge is down here is what
the insurance company sets our rate for
us when we make an agreement with them
they say we're going to pay you this
much
and then the specialist co-pays up here
usually by 10 or 15 dollars separation
and so the patients face the situation
where they
they just basically say
either they're going to foot it
themselves or or or they
they just
they bail out as far as that goes and
and this is they've been a lot of
studies now and i have to tell you some
great research coming out of new
hampshire
they use the the database that new
hampshire set up there are researchers
up at dartmouth college and some out in
southern california that have been
cranking out the research
that has demonstrated
one of them which came out in in 2015.
they used the database from the years
2013 and 14 they looked at 13 000 new
hampshire residents policyholders and
they found that there was a 55 percent
reduced likelihood that they would
utilize an opioid if they had
access to chiropractic care as their
first line
of treatment 55 percent
i sat down with the governor
representative longer and i have sat
with the governor and david meyer on
this on this information
we're trying to get opioid legislation
passed it also improves access to these
types of alternative as we love that
term these alternative
methods of care but they have they are
proving time and time again
to be beneficial in this battle against
against the use of the opioids
in conclusion i'd just like to say that
you know there's even been some
questions over the years as to the
legality
of this type of
behavior as far as giving us this
special designation that doesn't fit us
it's just not us
and even in one of um
my uh our interactions with mr brennan
from the insurance company back in
november of 2011 when we were working on
this
even in his um
um
his correspondence with us questioned
the legality of this he he indicated to
us that you know that these companies
have the ability to set their
co-payments with their where they want
and we agree with that
but he did say and i quote him we do
feel there is a potential legal issue
with the co-payments
exceeding what is otherwise due and that
they were going to look into it and
really nothing further that took place
as far as that goes we've tried to
work with them um
in this
but i i would hope that you would
consider this
bill very seriously
because there are
individuals out there that are not
getting their proper access because of
this profit enhancing
strategy
that the insurance companies are using
okay
um here are questions
represented below
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
uh so are you considering our
chiropractors considered
using alternative
treatments or similar to a naturopath
i think our official classifications we
are primary portal of entry
health care providers
we're not primary care physicians
we are primary portal in that we are
accessible directly without a referral
from a medical physician
that was an issue we addressed at one
point years ago uh mr chairman where the
where the gatekeeper as they were
referred to would have to give the
blessing
for the patient to go to the
chiropractor so i think mr chairman was
influential in helping us
address that issue
and now we're hopeful that this part of
the issue i mean we're just constantly
fighting
strategies
that come around that
are meant to restrict you know
our ability i mean
we they can limit the number of visits
they limit the amount that they're going
to pay us
but this this part is most painful
because it it throws the financial
responsibility on the patient
okay representative johnson
i have more of a would you
believe that
i actually have a i'm very grateful for
an insurance policy that gives me
unlimited chiropractic
which has been beneficial because it's
kept me pretty healthy over the last 10
20 years
and my co-pays are pretty low because
the insurance company that we have
um allows unlimited chiropractic
for my whole family
so it it is a beneficial
well yeah i mean to me it's
much more affordable than going to a
surgeon you know you know which is what
i hear people do all the time which
seems insane to me but um
so i guess my question is due
i guess i dare to do this because i
really shouldn't but i um
which companies are doing it because i'm
worried that that um the
we only can affect this legislation and
only affect small group health insurance
in individuals so i'm just wondering
um
is anthem and harvard are is that are
they part of the problem well i can i
can share with you that
anthem was
the initiator of this
strategy
and
actually we tried the work directly with
anthem
the first hearing we had on this was
actually over in the senate commerce
committee and at the time that the
chairman
he didn't want to mandate this he
thought that the marketplace might be
able to help you know manage this
problem it hasn't
um but i will never forget
in that hearing
the chairman pointed at the
representative from anthem and he said
this isn't right you need to fix it
and that's pretty much how the hearing
ended and we were optimistic but nothing
ever happened
now what now what happened also as we
were back and forth communicating with
them there was a point in time in april
of 2011
in our uh interactions with paula rogers
from from anthem
where in her communication to with mr
james monahan who was
our lobbyist at the time
when they actually indicated to us that
that they couldn't change this
designation because their computer
systems were
were a multi-state and and they couldn't
assure us that
with any
time element or anything of that nature
that they would be able to fix this
anytime soon that it was a computer
system issue
and so once again
we were left kind of you know kicking
the can down the road someone this is
why we keep coming back on on this this
issue it hasn't gone away in fact what
has happened is that
there have been other
insurance companies that have
probably noticed the effect
effectiveness of this strategy
and we have started to see these
these specialist co-pays creep up in
some other
policies as well
but i would suggest to you that it began
with the anthem
okay
uh representative macular just a quick
question if we if this bill passed
do you see any way that the insurance
companies could
do a backdoor thing to sort of offset it
well i'm sure there there is something
you know that that could take place i'm
i'm not savvy with
the the
with the possibilities that would be
there
uh my hope is that and in being here
talking about this that there's not some
type of punitive um
uh result that would occur either to us
as a profession or our patients uh
if some of these strategies were
to be to be nullified but
but you know
there are there are thousands of these
policies out there that are working very
well
for them i mean we don't hear
from the police or fire or teachers
where they're saying oh gee the the
chiropractors are running us broke you
know in fact the studies that are out
there demonstrate that as you increase
utilization for chiropractic utilization
you reduce costs on the medical side of
that equation
we end up and there are so many studies
that we have submitted on this over the
years where other anthems tennessee
anthem in
2010 i think it was
witnessed
millions of dollars of savings
when they increased their access to
chiropractic so we're not trying to
burden
uh the insurance companies with this uh
with this we really think and we truly
believe that if they actually used us
more that there they would see cost
savings we would see beneficial results
in the opioid
crisis
so many studies that are coming out of
dartmouth on this and i'm happy to share
these studies with you
in whatever fashion you would ever want
me to
but i would just say that
i'm sure there are strategies but i just
don't know what they would be
great thank you very much for your
testimony mr chairman thank you very
much okay
uh chair we'll call on dr ken gabriel
the new hampshire chiropractic
association
in support of the bill
hello mr chairman thank you um i'd like
to apologize in advance
i'm a little nervous i'm not a public
speaker this is uh very intimidating to
me
and um
just forgive my passion forgive my
emotion as i approach the subject from a
more anecdotal personal side having lost
family members to opioid addiction and
i'm sure i'm not the only one
in the room who has suffered loss
from this epidemic
i want to speak in support of this bill
from that perspective because i feel
like this is an opportunity
to make a difference
this is an opportunity for this group in
this room
to look at this situation and try to
take a small step in the right direction
in addressing the chronic pain
issues in this state and in this country
i happened to watch a tv series this
week called dope sick and i don't know
if anybody has seen it but i suggest you
look at it on hulu it's a very
disturbing
tv series with based in fact about the
opioid epidemic and its beginnings and i
think it rings true on an anecdotal
level in my life and i'm sure if you uh
see this series it may ring true in your
life as well
i think we have an opportunity as a
profession
to get in the trenches as dr stagnone
stated we are
portal of entry what does that mean that
means we are first line of defense
when somebody hurts their back they have
a choice and we know that there are
studies out there that say if you pick
up the phone and call a chiropractor you
are
47.2 percent less likely to go to
surgery
that's a huge statistic and i can get
you that study
so who you pick up and call as the first
line of defense
is certainly a great way to
limit
the entryway into the opioid
epidemic for for those people so the
chiropractors there is nobody more
competent in this country to treat lower
back pain as a matter of fact on the way
in today i had a chance to look up the
top three reasons why people go to see a
primary care physician
the first one was skin conditions the
second one was osteoarthritis
the third one was back pain
two out of the three chiropractors are
ready to deal with on the first level
basis now that doesn't mean we don't
send people for surgery if they need
surgery that doesn't mean we don't send
people
for
pharmacological treatment if necessary
but it's a lot less likely and it's an
alternative and now we're gaining
support by many different
studies that say that medical care
combined with chiropractic care and
alternative care and other forms of
conservative therapy are really
much better than medical care by itself
and pharmacological intervention so
again we're looking to work with the
medical field we're not looking to be
to be the primary source here but we
want to do our part we are educated to
do our part we we are the best spinal
manipulators in the world people from
across the world come
to the united states where chiropractic
was developed and studied and researched
so
taking my passion and saying this is an
opportunity for us
to make a small step and to bring equity
back to the patient and give the choice
back to the patient so it's not an
economic choice i can't afford six
visits to the chiropractor it's 70
dollar copay that's 420 dollars i don't
have is what i hear i heard it today
this morning seeing a patient doc i know
you want me to come for six visits i can
afford two
it severely limits my ability to treat a
patient and it's hurting the people of
new hampshire and i encourage you to
vote for this bill for that reason
thank you
representative greeson
thank you sir for uh for your testimony
by being one of these
first the line of first line of defense
do you
experience the access issues
that we have heard about especially with
mental health care
because
they require a referral and there may
not be enough providers in the network
taking new patients
since you are a first line of defense
where they can call you directly is
there an issue with lack of access and
then just on top of that would are you
aware of the the multi-billion dollar
settlement against johnson and johnson
just this week for their involvement in
the opioid crisis
i'm not aware of of the johnson johnson
situation but i can assure you there are
400 practicing chiropractors in the
state of new hampshire we have 400
licenses in the state
we do have some difficulties with the
more rural areas
you know most of us tend to be
concentrated in the more populist areas
but new hampshire is a small state we
have 400 practicing chiropractors new
hampshire is a great state to live in
and i know that we're adding licenses
every year we add licenses we're not
losing licenses every year we're
actually adding licenses every year
which is a great positive sign for our
profession and for our state in terms of
access that's great
all right thank you very much thank you
we got one more card left michelle
heaton from the insurance department
takes no position
hello again michelle heaton health law
and policy legal counsel for the
insurance department
as you said we don't take a position on
this we just want to provide some
background for this bill
we do have currently under our statutes
rsa420j6-b
self-referrals for chiropractor this is
the bill that i think
has been mentioned several times that
allows
if chiropractic coverage is part of your
insurance plan then you're entitled to
at least 12 visits
without a referral
back in
2014 we did have a bill that passed that
implemented cost-sharing parity
for chiropractic and pcp as part of that
bill the department was required to do a
couple studies to see how this panned
out over time so the first study was
done
in 2014 to kind of get a lay of the land
and then another updated one was done at
the end of 2017 which is when the parity
requirement sunseted
when we looked back
well starting with the the
2014 report
its conclusions were that consistent
with other studies lower co-payment
levels were associated with higher
spending on those services
the findings suggest that there was
partial substitution between
chiropractic services and other medical
services although not enough to offset
the system-wide cost of chiropractic
care
and consistent with past studies it was
found that any use of and the amount of
use of chiropractic care was associated
with lower use of opioids
so that was our starting point in 2017
the report came out in january of 2018
we looked back at what happened with
this parity requirement and generally
equalized cost sharing with primary care
services occurred but increased cost
sharing for primary care so there was
parity between this but overall the cost
of the co-pay amounts did go up
there was no assumptions made about this
relationship though
cairo cost sharing declined slightly and
utilization increased
lower cost sharing was associated with
higher utilization of chiropractic
services
and after risk
adjustment
an increase in spending on chiropractic
services is associated with an increase
in total spending when considering all
the conditions which chiropractic care
is used there is not enough of a
reduction in other services to make up
for the increase in chiropractic
services spending this results in an
overall increase in total spending
and there was an association though not
statistically significant between use of
chiropractic care and lower opioid use
so like i said in 2017 these provisions
sunseted so currently there is no parity
requirement but i think a lot of the
testimony we've heard is the overall
cost of chiropractic care
and
insurance coverage of that and i don't
think necessarily that this bill is
going to address those issues i don't
have to take any questions and also
those two reports are available on the
insurance department's website if you
want to read up on it and get
your mind just sending us the link where
it is so we can we can find that so i
think that would be very helpful
any questions
cnn thank you very much
so representative burrows i just
remembered we we passed a limitation on
insulin for diabetics
we capped
the copays and deductibles at a hundred
dollars
i think if i'm correct
um
so this is 12 45. uh lindsay nano from
cigna is opposed and heidi kroll from
ahip is also opposed
and
do i have this is 12 45 which one
midnight writer
59 people in support and nobody opposed
and with that i will close the public
hearing you survive
so um
maybe
okay do we do we have the sign-in cheat
does anybody see the the clipboard with
the sign-in sheet
oh here it is
okay
all right
so um why don't we have some
opportunity for people to introduce
themselves who are
visiting us today
they're awesome
i'm uh ross barry i represent the town
of litchfield and southern manchester
awards eight and nine and i'm psyched to
be here and
he will be replacing max abramson
and yes
hello mr chairman i'm larry laflamme i'm
from coast three which is the city of
berlin
welcome to congress
and then we have
jared
hi i'm sheri dutzy from nashua ward 3
hillsboro 30. and i'm sitting in for
christina fargo there you go okay
so theoretically we have a full house
all right i will go in uh numeric order
and the first bill i have here for the
exec session is house bill
relative to cigar bars
and uh representative patusik seconded
uh by representative hunt moves uh the
amendment on house bill 1237
and christine how many people have
gotten
gotten that amendment is
how many people
on 12 37
yeah so i know we had the amendment was
distributed earlier today
so
okay
i think we're
just anybody who doesn't have one who
would like to have one just stick your
hand up in the air
okay representative representative tusek
you're recognized to speak to your
motion
uh i move otp on um
amendment 2022-0428h
amending
hb1237
i moved to
uh
i moved to uh ought to pass on uh
amendment
uh 0428h amended amend
the amendment of house bill 1237 fn and
you are recognized to speak to your
motion
um it amends the bill by replacing all
fdd and acting cause
adding
more tobacco products
to the uh
gill
right so it moves it from the exemptions
to the uh
included items
for
the 60 requirement any discussion on the
motion about to pass on the amendment
see none the clerk will call the roll
and just question who was it seconded by
me okay
all right calling the role
representative patousek yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
berry yes
representative
ham representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes
representative terry
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel no
representative herbert no
representative dutsy
mike representative laflamme
representative weston
yes
representative bellew
no
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes
15 to 3 motion passes okay
representative patusek seconded by
representative hunt musa out to pass has
amended any uh discussion on the motion
scene on the clerk we'll call the role
when he's ready
okay
representative
and i i forgot to call you last time so
16 to 1. i'm assuming you're 16 yes 16
to three
all right
it's my first time doing this on paper
all right representative uh patusek yes
representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
uh
berry yes
representative hamm
representative de palma
representative greeson
yes
representative johnson
representative terry
yes
representative bartlett yes
representative abel no
representative herbert no
representative
dutsy
yes
representative leflam yeah
representative weston yes
representative bellew
no
representative burroughs yes
representative mcaleer
yes representative hunt yes
16 to 3.
okay uh
those three are you okay with putting
this on the exec
on the uh consent calendar
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna write a
minority report
okay then it won't go in there okay
regular calendar all right uh next bill
is 1469.
uh representative greeson seconded by
representative hunt moves
ought to pass on the amendment
do we have the amendment the amendment
was distributed earlier so
zero three four two
three four two
oh two seven one
three four two three four h
and representative greeson's recognized
to speak to his motion
oh i've got it
thank you mr chair
we have uh
we are entering a different era of
discrimination
how people are are potentially going to
be discriminated against it's not as
clear and cut as a person's gender or
their color of their skin
it's going into
areas that we
never would have imagined when when
initial discrimination laws were written
so in order to protect everyone against
this type of discrimination it's
unfortunate that a bill like house bill
1469 would even need to be written it
protects everyone regardless of your
political philosophy regardless of of uh
other things that again are being or
will be as they are becoming more aware
of the types of discrimination so this
is truly an
anti-discrimination bill
and so
just trying to protect businesses
protect consumers and individual people
alike from this type of discrimination
thank you
question
representative bartlett thanks mr chair
so my question would be then
if a an abortion clinic came
for
a fund funding
then there would be no discrimination
regarding that occupancy is that correct
if an abortion clinic goes to
a bank
and wants to open an account
conduct its
transactions they're they they they
cannot
discriminate against that based on that
political philosophy
that would be for any loans for in doing
any business
that is correct okay thank you
any other discussion on the motion of
ought to pass on the amendment
yes representative could you remind me
or remind the committee and the
people in the audience how many people
signed it signed in in or opposed do you
have the blue sheet there in the folder
uh i'm not sure we have the blue sheet
here no the folder no no we don't
actually have the folder here sorry we
don't have any information on it
well
in terms of the amendment or turn the
original bill
either one yeah i i'm sorry we don't
have the folder that you know that
because i i think the general public
needs to know how many people signed in
in or uh for or oppose this bill
to this bill
okay
uh because we're we are representing
constituents
sorry that's anecdotal we don't have the
question is uh when we had the public
hearing
who signed in on the blue sheet for and
against it
do you really want to recess and get
that number is that really that
important
well i think it makes a difference
really i mean
really okay so if there's
if there's 50 people opposed
and five that are for the bill
and we passed the bill what does that
say about the constituents that we're
representing
so
my experience with people signing in
that there have been some lobbyists
efforts
to you know get people to send in and
you know get online and do that so i
mean i i respect anybody's opinion in
doing it but at the end of the day we
vote on what we think is the right for
new hampshire i don't
i don't i would never say that i've
suddenly
decided that way i feel about a bill is
certainly wrong suddenly because i got
hundreds and hundreds of emails telling
people for me to vote against something
that i think is a good idea
so i'm not i'm not sure i would ever do
that but if you know if you really want
to recess are you going are you going to
ask this for every bill no no no i just
wanted to pose a question because i
think okay okay and i think if this mr
chair if this is the only bill that we
don't have that information for i really
do think we should have it okay well
we're in recess and we'll go get the
phone
it doesn't
matters
i have the file in front of me um on the
the people who
log in the night before
i have uh 89
in support
and four opposed
oh see you like that example when i gave
that
thank you mr chair
i was tracking
all right any more discussion on them
we're out of recess officially we're out
of recess uh any more discussion on the
motion of ought to
uh pass the amendment
right have we done the amendment yet no
no no we haven't done the amendment is
any more discussion on the motion about
to pass on the amendment seeing down the
clerk will call the roll
okay i have uh moved by greece and
seconded by hunt on amendment 342h
calling the roll
representative patusik yes
representative osborne representative
ammon yes representative barry yes
representative ham
representative palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett no
representative abel
no
representative herbert
representative dutsy no representative
laflamme no
representative weston no
representative belyou
representative burroughs no
representative mcmacler no
and representative hunts yes
10 to nine
okay the motion pass is 10-9
representative greeson second by
representative patusek moves out to pass
as amended is there any discussion on
the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
when he's ready
okay representative patusek i'll to pass
as amended representative
representative osborne yes
representative amman yes representative
berry yes representative ham
representative de palma representative
greeson yes representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett no
representative abel
no representative herbert
representative dutsy no representative
laflem
representative weston no
representative bell you
no
representative burroughs no
representative mcelroy no representative
hunts
yes 10 to none all right the motion
passes we'll leave that on the regular
calendar
i'll do the minority report mr chair and
there would be a minority report
okay next up uh house bill 1502 uh
representative ammon seconded by
representative patusik moo's interim
study
any discussion on the motion of interim
see none
the clerk will call the roll when he's
ready
okay interim study on 1502
representative batusik yes
representative osborne representative
ammond yes representative berry yes
representative ham
representative de palma
representative greeson
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes
representative bartlett
yes
representative abel
representative herbert
representative dutsy
yes representative laflem yeah
representative weston yes
representative bellew
yes
representative burroughs yes
representative mclear yes representative
hunt
yes 22-0
oh what did i do wrong here
19-0
all right
adding text adding members to the
committee
i counted ross berry twice i think okay
all right the motion passes 19 to zip
all those in favor placing on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay
uh
just so uh i know on your sheets it
might say uh house bill 1503 we will not
be executing that bill today
next up is house bill 1504
uh relative to special purpose
depository institution
institutions represented ammon seconded
by represent patusek moves inexpedient
to legislate and house bill 1504
is there any discussion on the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
on house bill eddie speaking to
legislate on 1504.
representative patousek yes
representative osborne yes
representative ammon yes representative
barry yes representative ham
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry representative
bartlett yes representative abel yes
representative herbert
representative dutsy yes representative
leflamb yeah representative weston yes
representative bell you yes
representative burroughs
representative mclear yes representative
hunts
yes
19-0 all those in favor of placing 1504
on the consent calendar please say aye
aye those opposed
so moved unanimously
next up house bill 1523
representative johnson seconded by
representative patusik
the moose in expedition to legislate on
establishing a new hampshire child care
fund representative johnson is
recognized to speak to our motion
excuse me
i believe we have a bill over in the
senate that will help
change all this there is another bill
that is a study committee on the issue
right so this bill is not needed
any more discussion on the motion of an
expedient to legislate
seeing none the clerk will call the
robin
representative
yes representative osborne
representative amman yes representative
berry yep
representative ham representative palmer
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry yes representative
bartlett yes representative abel yes
representative herbert yes
representative van halton
no she's not here today oh geez
she substitutes you who is the what's up
representative
uh yes
and representative flam
representative weston yes
representative bell you yes
representative burroughs
representative mclean yes representative
hunts yes 19-0 okay the vote passes at
19-0 all those in favor putting on the
consent calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay um house bill 1589 prohibiting the
sale of products containing
intentionally added pfas
representative johnson seconded by
representative patusek moo's
interim study
is there any discussion on the motion of
say none the clerk will call the role
representative patousik yes
representative osborne representative
ammon yes representative abramson yes
barry i mean representative hamm
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes representative
herbert
representative dutsy yes
representative leflam yeah
representative weston yes
representative bellew yes representative
burroughs representative mclear yes and
representative hunts yes 19-0 all those
in favor placing on the consent calendar
please say aye
aye those opposed so moved unanimously
and uh
okay house bill 1591 eliminating the
enforcement division of the liquor
commission
uh representative hunt uh second by
representative patusek moves interim
study
and uh this obviously this is a big bear
of an issue and we just want to spend
some time to review it properly and
before we
make
proper judgment
of what we think
the finance committees
concerns are being addressed
with that
in no more discussion uh
the clerk will call the roll on interim
study
representative patusik yes
representative osborne
representative amman yes representative
berry representative hamm representative
palmer representative greeson yes
representative johnson
yes representative terry representative
bartlett yes
representative abel yes representative
herbert
representative dutsy
yes representative leflam yeah
representative weston yes
representative bell you yes
representative burroughs representative
mclean yes representative hans yes 19-0
all those in favor placing 1591 on the
consent calendar please say aye
aye those opposed
so move unanimously
and last but not least house bill 1622
relative to mental health parity
and we have an amendment for it
and
this amendment
number is four five zero
it's coming around
yeah i told her to hold on to them so we
don't lose them so we want to make sure
all the committee members get copies
before indeed i found a one that was
incorrect
i had copies made and read it
right
so representative bartlett did you get a
copy yet
no okay so you're getting yours now okay
well good because um thank you
representative bartlett seconded by
representative hunt moves on to pass on
the amendment
that she is now about to
read i'm sorry
yeah okay
do you want me yeah why don't you speak
to what's it's
i i think i'm i'm very encouraged that
we were able to
work this through there are a number of
people involved the carriers are
involved
and
we're hoping that this will
encourage
the providers to
um
pay at a
reasonable
level as well as open up the market
for um accessibility
for um
mental health
providers that you know that we need we
need their help
so hopefully this um amendment does it
it's helpful
so you want to describe what the two
paragraphs do or
um sure the um let's see the first
i'm reading all my different notes
um currently required by federal law to
include current list of providers
accepting patients so
the
bill this amendment replaces all of the
bill
from the original bill managed care law
provider contract standards inserting
every contract entered into after
september 1st of 2022
between the healthcare and any
healthcare provider she'll contain a
provision that requires the healthcare
provider to notify the carrier when the
healthcare provider is no longer
accepting new patients
this still puts the onus on the provider
having to tell the the carrier
and then coverage for certain
biologically based mental illnesses
notwithstanding under any other
provision
each insurer the issues or renews any
policy of accident or health
in each non-profit health
blah blah blah providing disease
benefits for disease or sickness in the
state of new hampshire shall provide
benefits for treatment and diagnosis of
certain biologically based mental
illnesses under
access standards established in rsa 420
j colon 7 and under terms and conditions
which are no less extensive than the
coverage provided for any other type of
health care
or for physical illness so that's where
the mental health parity
comes in
great
any more discussion on the motion of uh
to pass on the amendment for 1622
saying none the clerk will call the roll
and i have moved by bartlett seconded by
hunt correct
representative patusik
yes representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
barry representative hamm representative
palmer
representative greeson representative
johnson
yes representative terry representative
bartlett
yes representative abel
yes representative herbert
representative dutsy yes
representative
leflamb representative weston yes
representative bell you yes
representative burroughs
representative mcelier yes
representative hunt yes 19-0 okay
representative bartlett seconded by
representative hunt moves out to pass on
house bill 1622 is there any discussion
on the motion saying now the clerk will
call the roll when he's ready
representative patousik
yes representative osborne
representative ammon yes representative
berry yes representative hamm
representative de palma
representative greeson yes
representative johnson yes
representative terry
representative bartlett yes
representative abel yes representative
herbert
representative dutzy yes representative
laflamme yes representative weston yes
representative bellew
yes representative burroughs
representative mclear yes representative
hunts
yes 19-0
okay
all those in favor placing house bill
1622 on the consent calendar please say
aye
those opposed
so moved unanimously
and we're out of executive session
mr chair did you up mr chair who says we
can't get it done in 45 minutes
you did it
um
do you want me to do the report for the
consent calendar
okay
thank you
now you got a little taste of what i'm
doing here
i run a very tight ship are you serious
we'll open up the public hearing
on
1501 and hear from the former member of
the commerce committee
macbeth
what a pleasure to see you again
you gotta press the button press it
and we're told it's completely opposite
what is in the courts that's what i was
gonna yes yes so for all you lawyers who
are
trial lawyers this is opposite it's
completely different so you see the
green light that's a bad thing
so anyway thank you and um so i'm becky
macbeth i
was a member of this committee for six
wonderful years i'm now in judiciary but
i have to say i used to always wonder
when members would come in and say you
know i used to be here and i didn't
recognize them i kind of felt sorry for
them and then i also wondered if they
were still doing quite as much work as
we were so i want to tell you that um i
am doing quite a bit of work but maybe
not as much
um so i'm here today to introduce a bill
um that i think was heard all three
sessions that i said on this committee
it's hb
1501 fn
and i'm going to try to say this right
it's um it's regarding um insurance
coverage for pediatric autoimmune
neuropsychic disorders
um and you probably have heard the um
acronym pandas or pans i really don't
that is what
this is referring to or that but i think
that that acronym is kind of getting
misused we're finding out more about
these
neuropsychic autoimmune disorders and
but
about
three years ago this committee heard
had heard
testimony from citizens in new hampshire
that were having trouble
getting insurance companies when their
family members had been
diagnosed with
this coverage from this
treatment called it's iv ig
but it's intravenous
immunoglobulin therapy and i'm so
embarrassed that i can't say those i
should but that therapy i can't really
scientifically describe it to you but
it's a lot what the therapy that you get
when you've been exposed to rabies it's
a blood um
product byproduct of other people's
blood and you know they depending on
your height and weight and what your
symptoms are it's got other things mixed
in it but it's a very expensive
treatment and
some of the citizens felt like they
weren't getting that
approved by insurance companies so
about three years ago we added into the
committee added into the legislation
that it would be covered by new
hampshire health insurers and that that
treatment specifically would be
offered or approved if if it was
recommended by the provider
so i'm here now because the sun sets
coming up in
2004. and
so i don't want to feel like i'm
reneging on my deal because i think
there was concern at the time that we
passed that there might be a run on
insurance companies that there would be
a huge demand for this or that
maybe it wasn't going to be an effective
treatment i'm not really sure all the
reasons but i think none of that has
panned out and i i think that um
you're going to hear from the insurers
themselves or their representatives but
i think this has been you know an
effective tool for citizens to use
people have been getting treatment
and
i don't think it's been you know
overused by providers
as well as you know during this covet
time people have put off some of their
treatment so
there's another issue that i asked for
an extension of that so this is kind of
a permanent extension but um you know we
can hear that out and i i saw that i
think the chairman has scheduled it for
a subcommittee hearing next week
amazing how quickly that happens
all right so thank you very much i will
take questions but i think probably
people behind me might have better
responses for those
i guess you're off the oh oh i'm
confused
representative johnson has
her hand up first
thank you for taking my question
um i was in another committee
and a similar issue was brought up um
but what they did was they took us uh 3
000 foot view and included you know
other
disorders and stuff
could this be maybe amended to include
some other disorders and or treatments
that we might see
the same thing happening so we're not
just targeting one but we're we're
expanding it to other pieces that may be
falling into these cracks also
that would
be a question i think for the committee
to look into pandas itself
is a broad spectrum of
conditions and symptoms and it's still
you know very i think malleable as far
as how it's going to be defined
i think if you're talking about some of
those or if you're just talking about
other
issues that you know or diagnosis or
that people are having trouble getting
coverage for um i i wouldn't comment on
that
representative bartlett did you have a
question thank you mr chair so um
representative macbeth we're glad to
have you back we know we worked hard on
this for two terms i think it was before
we got this through so all you're asking
is that the sunset
crosby repeal is that what you're asking
yes that's what i'm asking um
it's very short and it's actually we put
in two phrases but it's just the last
phrase the the
recognizing the pandas disorders as a um
you know
diagnostic
what i don't know what it would be
diagnostic code or i don't know if
there's a code or not but um
that would stay it's just this iv ig
treatment that
we like to
extend
can i follow up where's the question you
mean claire thank you so um
we had this
last year
didn't we because i think we had the
insurance department come in and say
that it's been really tough to code this
because it is such an unusual
condition
um
should i just wait and ask tyler i think
actually i think um
townie manful who's here might have some
and i know that tyler's here to give a
history but i'm glad that you mentioned
that as well because one of the reasons
why i'd like to extend the deadline is
because
i and i had filed a bill before about
trying to collect data it's been really
hard to collect data i didn't realize
how hard it was or how much time
probably too much time then that you
know we want as legislators for the
department of um insurance to put in on
it so what the trade-off for that is
since we can't get the data to let it go
longer so maybe that data will trickle
down or you know we can get something
that's more
you know usable to educate the
legislators about it you know is this
working and do we want to keep it
yeah
read the fiscal note the little
paragraph there that's it's helpful to
get the history
okay thank you thank you
uh and one card tyler
he's back
we missed you tyler
okay so tyler brennan life and health
director with the new hampshire
insurance department we do not have a
position on the bill and
agree it is about repealing the sunset
date the
this is a little bit of an unusual
mandate so
when insurance coverage is provided it's
provided on the basis of scopus services
so think hospital services think
ambulance services think surgery they're
in collaboratory
if a carrier were to decide well we're
not going to cover
care for diabetics
we're not going to cover care for people
with a particular mental health
condition we would consider that
discriminatory and that would be a
prohibited practice what's unusual about
pandas is that there's some disagreement
in the medical community about the
condition and how it should be best
treated so typically if there is a
determination by an insurance carrier
that treatment is not medically
necessary for the condition there's kind
of an appeals process including an
external appeals process that would go
to clinicians and they would decide
whether or not treatment is medically
necessary i think the reason that this
this mandate passed and the way it did
is because there wasn't enough
confidence in that appeals process to
get to a place where coverage would be
provided consistently
because it's a condition that's a little
less specific a little bit um
more vague within the medical community
the diagnosis code in other words the
code that gets submitted on the claim
form describing the condition that
somebody has is actually a general code
it's described as other specified
disorders involving the immune mechanism
not elsewhere classified one of the
questions we had about a year ago was
well how many patients are showing up
in insurers coverage how many patients
are showing up in the claims data that
we have collected in an anonymous way
and how much are those patients costing
well we all agree that this code is
probably not going to be the best it may
bring in other patients but let's
explore to figure out whether or not
it's at all reliable and whether or not
there was an increase in the number of
people who recovered after the
legislation passed including the the
mandate and we did the analysis and we
quickly determined the code was not
going to be reliable there were a lot of
adults under that diagnosis code so
really just a lot of false positives the
legislation that was considered about a
year ago actually would look at kind of
a reporting requirement for insurance
companies to report to the insurance
department
because they're going to be in the same
place the same problem they're not going
to identify in the claims data they
would have to do something like prior
authorization or some sort of case
management to identify the patients keep
track of the information report the cost
to us so any type of retrospective
reporting really wouldn't work very well
you'd have to kind of set it up
prospectively and that ended up sort of
not actually moving forward so the place
we are today is is again i mean kind of
evaluating on a long-term basis whether
or not a mandate that is targeting a
specific condition
is something that you want to do and i
think actually the question that was
raised is a good one because once you
start to go down that road about trying
to identify all the conditions you
expect insurance to coverage
that potentially raises questions about
what if anything that's not included i
mean we've always looked at it from
anything that's excluded is
discriminatory but if you came up with a
robust enough list it's kind of like
well wait a minute how are we going
about this so that's a kind of a word of
caution and to the extent that the
condition the treatment evolve over time
it's rare our statutes keep up with
those changes so it's just sort of
another area of caution i mean typically
if you want kind of a mandate scope of
services work pretty well but again if
they're too specific
the practice of medicine can change and
you may need to adjust it that being
said there's this is clearly a very
emotional subject for a lot of people
and there appears to have been problems
with people getting coverage and
treatment for it we heard that during
testimony over the years the insurance
department has not received complaints
about coverage on it the only thing i'm
aware of is we heard from a physician at
one of the hospitals dartmouth who was
raising questions about whether or not
mcos were covering it and we had to
explain that no that the mandate
requirement is for commercial insurance
it wouldn't apply to the medicaid mcos
so that's that's i guess that's as much
as i can offer you in terms of insight
happy to take any questions though
would there be any way to improve the
language or because i i think i i'm
i'm sure this sunset was put in for a
reason
to say that if we don't really get
viable information then probably best
just let it go
so how do you feel any way we can make
this work better or should we just let
it sunset
um that's certainly a policy decision i
haven't heard any complaints about the
way it's described in terms of coverage
and again because we haven't received
complaints about people not getting
coverage or being interpreted
in a way that's not beneficial i'm not
sure it could offer improvements i think
that it's it is a policy decision
whether or not you want to keep this on
the books indefinitely or or maintain a
sunset date that may be more sensitive
to
changes over time or
different feelings about including
specific conditions and treatment in
statute
representative bartlett um thanks mr
chair so i'm wondering um there was only
one pink card because i'd sure like to
hear from the insurance carriers
about whether they've been covering this
expensive
i'd love i'd love to hear from
from anthem or harvard pilgrim or um
travelers you know if if you're actually
covering this because it's it must come
out in your reports
so i can i can tell you that the
diagnosis code that they would use when
these patients are being treated are
being that is being submitted by
providers and it is being paid for by
insurance companies i just don't i can't
tell because adults are in there how
many of those patients are for pandas
right
but can you tell whether they're doing
it because we passed the statue or
whether they would have been covering it
anyways
so there aren't a lot of patients in
general there did not appear to be an
increase after the legislation passed so
it's possible that it would have been a
reduction had the legislation not passed
but um you know there's no way we could
look like any change okay yeah
okay
thank you very much thank you
paula do you want to weigh in
did you do do you sign the blue sheet on
this at all or
okay
so um i i guess from the anthem point of
view we're well aware of pandas we were
part of the discussion with
representative macbeth and a number of
uh families that were here and testified
before the committee
and the
provision has been in place now probably
get a little closer to your mic so our
ocr can pick you up okay so um the
provision's been in place for some time
i think beyond the data challenges that
tyler brannon pointed out
one good place to look would be to
internally and each insurer go to your
people that handle customer service and
complaints and appeals and grievances
and ask them whether they've had
anything at all that would point out
that pandas has become an issue i.e that
parents are not seeing that insurance
company is responding appropriately we
have no
knowledge of such complaint
and one thing i think will give you
maybe a little bit of pause is the fact
that the treatments for this condition
are somewhat in dispute
so i think all physicians pediatricians
mostly
or behavioral health specialists in
collaborative care with a pediatrician
seeing a child in some distress
may not be able to come to a pandas
diagnosis or may come to one but if they
come to one and they go to a
practitioner a pediatrician they're apt
to get a number of treatments before
ivig
the immunoglobulin
treatment that representative macbeth
referred to
that is really the purpose of this
mandate in new hampshire is to make that
treatment available
and when that was proposed
i can't remember exactly who testified
but i know what anthem was reluctant to
have that put into statute because there
was clinical disagreement out in the
ether amongst those people that debate
about these things as to whether ivig
was indeed a good or appropriate
treatment
i remember giving testimony about
i think it was the american academy of
pediatricians had looked at that issue
and had wanted to back away from an
initial embrace of ivig
there was one other treatment it was
called apheresis a
e a-p-h-e-r-s-i-s i think
and that is where the individual's blood
would actually be
threatened
sent through some sort of a
cleansing mechanism which was another
treatment which was more as as you know
it's sort of a
substantial treatment as ivig is
my guess is that there aren't many
pediatricians that are going to come up
with a patient that has an advanced
situation that would even give them the
thought of ivig because they would go
through protocols around
antibiotic treatment
steroids treatment
maybe behavioral modification and
behavioral
modification
training with a child who's evidencing
you know psychiatric and behavioral
mechanisms that are alarming
so i just you know i'm not so sure the
demand is out there in new hampshire but
if it's been out there we at anthem are
not aware
that we have denied it and we certainly
wouldn't it's under state law if a
physician says that's the treatment they
want then that's the treatment they're
going to get in new hampshire
and so that's where it is now and again
as tyler said there's a puzzlement and
as representative mcbeath said there's
this continuing concern about this
challenging issue and as you said
representative hunt there are many
families that are very distressed about
the fact that their child may have this
condition which doesn't have any easy
answers
but anthem is neutral on this that's
what i would like to say
okay great thank you
i do have another card
william manful
support of the bill
thank you
i'm here really on behalf of our family
some of you may recognize me from
the original sb224
but we lost our daughter
alexandra at 26 years old to
complications related to pandas
and we feel as parents that
had we known more about this condition
and more importantly had the medical
community had known more we probably
would still have our daughter
since then my wife and i have been very
uh
actively trying to
promote awareness of pandas education
and even supportive research
but as was discussed here
there's still some unknowns that we're
trying to to
get answers to
but one of the things we do know
is that some of the treatments are
working for those more
serious cases and ivig is one of those
treatments that does work
if you're
if you're a patient then you reach a
chronic stage
so i'm really here to say i think
um i'm in supportive of removing the
sunset claws and i think there's a
couple of
developments that may help in this
decision
one is as was alluded to the the coding
of pandas made it very hard to
actually look at data and have an
informed decision about how well is a
bill working
i can tell you anecdotally in talking to
other parents it has made a difference
if you're
if you have
a child with pandas in new hampshire
with the new hampshire insurance company
it has made a difference and that's a
positive
the challenge with the coding is that
until recently there was no specific
code for pandas
what recently has happened is the icd
codes
starting in october were made available
for pandas and i believe in
in approximately five years icd-12
will have a specific code for pandas but
as of today physicians can submit a
diagnosis
under
icd-8989
which will help us in gathering data in
terms of how effective
and and and quantify what the problem is
and that helps people like my wife and i
to get the word out there and and to
inform the public
and to support families not just in new
hampshire but
throughout
the country
so
i think if anything the reason
one argument may be
that
the data the ability to really look at
the data was probably delayed a bit from
when we first passed the bill but now
we're coming in with more research and
we have some diagnostic codes that allow
us to
collect information from the insurance
companies i think we're at a more
meaningful point
and i fear that we'll run out of time to
really be able to properly evaluate the
effectiveness of the bill
so that would be one point the other
point is that ivig
is is a very costly
but very critical
treatment for the most chronic cases but
the cost of it is beyond what a family
can really endure without serious
sacrifice
and the research on ivag there's just
one that came out in italy recently but
there's actually a quite a large
state street clinical trial that's now
underway
through octafarma who's a manufacturer
of ivig
and the results given
it always takes longer than we would
like as uh as is on this side of the
fence but
the results of that probably won't be
really known for the next four to five
years
so what i'm really
hoping can happen is that at least this
bill be extended
if it's not rep if it's not the sunset
repealed to be extended such time as
some of this uh very important clinical
trial work that's happening right now
has a chance to show results what the
results are and at that point i believe
that there would be sufficient data for
this body to really decide whether the
bill is necessary and should continue
but in the meantime i don't want
families to be caught without protection
until such time as that data does become
available so i think based on that what
i would suggest is that
if we can't um
remove the sunset claws at least extend
it so that there's ample time because
there is momentum and there is now
the ability to actually track
against the the claims and and and see
the relevance of this bill but i can
tell you it's had an impact
and we would want to continue that
protection for new hampshire families
thank you thank you for coming
okay i have no more cards
anybody else want to speak and see none
we'll close
well before i close the public hearing
the
um blue sheet uh blue sheet has
nobody in support one person opposed
so
okay
with that i will
close the public hearing
on 1501.
it's not 12 minutes
now
i'm
with that
that is true
okay
thank you very much
your two cars
you know so
you never cease to amaze me
all my years all my years as a
legislator
and for those of you who are new members
who don't know about this but
when you
forget to vote when the buzzer goes off
you then have to do the walk of shame
down to
the uh the clerk's uh booth and
record your vote they would not let you
do a hand signal you had to do
this and everybody does oohs and oz and
and i don't know how many years have i
been doing this and i've never ever had
to do that except once
when susan olympus was my seat mate
and i had to do the walk of shame
that was quite a session that those two
years since it was
all we had to do was to
pay a little more attention maybe
what she was probably doing something to
preoccupy me or something i couldn't pay
attention so
good afternoon
and welcome to the commerce committee
thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee for hearing this bill
um
the the reason i actually
uh even know about
pbms is because i was listening to a
radio program
and someone from ohio who had been
introducing legislation there
about pbms
where they were informing everyone and i
was like boy you know that's supposed to
save us all money when we go to the
drugstore and get our prescriptions
filled
so i thought well
i wonder if anybody's doing that here in
new hampshire
so
i
decided that i would introduce this bill
i am no expert
it's extremely complex i probably can't
answer very many questions but i'm going
to read some of the key provisions of
this bill and i this you have a
single page two-sided copy of the
provisions and um key provisions and the
importance of those provisions
one of the things that i
we you know we're trying to get bill our
bills down our electric bills and our uh
medication bills down i mean just about
everybody i know has some kind of
medication or another that they have to
pay for
so
that's that's what the impetus for this
is
so i'm just going to read this and and
you could read along and i also
printed out just a
just a few
sheets of information on this
pbms are pharmacists
oh god help me out here
benefit
manager managers thank you
because i'd never heard of them i mean
it was something all new to me
so the key provisions of this bill is
that it requires licensure of pbms by
the new hampshire commission
commissioner now
just off the bat
i don't like regulation i don't like
bigger government and i don't like the
idea of
of
governmental overreach but it almost
seems to me that
the pharmaceutical industry
these pbms after checking them out a
little bit seem to be almost um
well i don't want to say racketeering
what's the word
manipulative no not manipulative they're
they're they're uh
no
well whatever it'll come it'll come to
me
is that autonomous representative
they operate in their own little it's no
it's not so much that because they're
they're actually subcontracted by the
insurance companies but one of the
things
in the supply chain
for from manufacturer to us when we go
get our our meds
there are all these different
you know the guys that deliver it the
guys that manufacture it the pharmacies
all of that and the there's and the
insurance companies
and the insurance companies definitely
have some
say in what goes on but the pbms
actually can see all of it
so and if the if the price of the drugs
go up then they get paid more and right
now
the worldwide industry they made 450
billion dollars profit last year they
get somewhere in the neighborhood of 50
cents for every dollar
and so i just thought wow that's uh
profiteering that's the word so anyway
i see mr chairman shaking his head at me
john you know you love me
okay so anyway requires this this the
keepers provisions of this bill requires
licensure of pm pbms by the new
hampshire commissioner uh the
commissioner can revoke licenses for a
variety of reasons allows the
commissioner to audit the pbm at their
discretion to confirm they are in
compliance with the laws and rules
creates reporting requirements for the
pbms which must be reported annually or
more frequently as determined by the
commissioner
and the importance of this is that this
system of count of accountability
through licensure
and creating uh consequences for
provisions of state law
are not followed as
if they're not followed it's vital as
they have been
there have been allegations of pbms
ignoring legal requirements um in other
states we're not the only state and i
know new hampshire does have
some oversight registration
thank you registration
thank you
so
which is actually
we're a little better off than a lot of
states that don't have any of that
and the pbms just go wild
okay second key provision increases
patient access to pharmacies and their
medications which we all want all of
that i don't even know anybody who there
are very few people who don't go get
something that they need
uh this requires the pbm's network
cannot be comprised of only mail order
but should have a mix of mail order and
physical stores in new hampshire one of
the things this that the pbms actually
own
along with the insurance companies it's
very complex
they have mail-in
prescription
companies and they have their hands
right in that till
the importance is this will ensure that
patients have access to physical
pharmacies if they prefer to fill their
medications there and have access to a
pharmacy if they need to urgently fill a
medication
it bans pbms from limiting patients from
choosing their own pharmacy or
pharmacist which happens you sort of get
locked into going to a certain place and
the importance there is there have been
uh reports of patients being steered to
only receive their medications through
mail in
pharmacies which are often also owned by
the the pbm
i i just
this can result in this
severing of a long-standing patient
pharmacist relationship and limiting
patient choice as to where they can
receive their medications uh it bans
pbms from collecting cost share and that
exceeds totals uh submitted charges by
the pharmacy which happens
i mean how can you how can you charge
more than what it costs i
the the
it blows my mind
uh
it bans points of sale and retroactive
fees importance by banning these fees
pharmacies will have a more
substantial business model which will
help to maintain their practice this
will ensure patients continue to have
access to their pharmacies and
pharmacists and one of the things that's
happening that's mom and pop
apothecaries kind of are getting
squished out and the the larger
companies that have the bigger
pharmacies are
gaining
puts it also puts restrictions on pbm's
lowering reimbursements for 340b drugs
importance this will ensure the
most vulnerable members of our community
continue to have access to their
medications and access to the pharmacies
where they fill their medications
this is this is fairly we're almost done
guys um it sets reimbursements for nadac
plus
10.49 dispensing fee and i to be honest
with you i need to look at and see what
the heck that is the national average
drug acquisition cost
um
it bans pbms from discriminating in
their reimbursement between different
pharmacies and the importance there is
that
there have been numerous reports of
pharmacy closures that are a result of
unsustainable business models often
attributed to bb pbm practices by
banning point of sale and retroactive
active fees and setting a baseline
reimbursement
anti-competitive practices will be
limited and pharmacies will be able to
maintain their practices ensuring
greater patient access to their local
community pharmacists so that's
kind of it in a nutshell
and and as i said before i mean i can
try to take questions but i don't know
how i'm not technically savvy here
actually the chairman probably is a lot
more technically savvy than i am
representative herbert has a question
um
just a question is i think we have
somebody in the audience from anthem
and i believe anthem brought their pbm
in-house
i'm not sure if that's the case would be
nice but i would like to that's your
question to it i would i would would you
believe that was bringing the pbm in
house
i would believe that okay
i would like to if i get the opportunity
to listen to the anthem
paul hasn't put a card in yet but
okay representative burroughs
yes as uh
here we have a statement from the um
the the insurance
insurance folks here in the state house
and they say that the licensure could
mean that prices of drugs would actually
go up because of the added expense
to the pbms i'm wondering what what your
take is on that
well i do know that if the price of
medications go up then the pbms actually
make more money so they'd be happy with
that because the more that the more
money that the the
medications cost the more money that the
pbms can collect i don't know where to
cite that for you
follow-up um how did this question be
inquired but would you believe that
if the prices go up that the consumers
are going to be the ones who who pay
that incremental amount
well we're going to be working on this
um
over time
so
i'm pretty sure i know where this is all
going to go
once once i leave here
but that's fine because we we want to
start
working and paying attention to this a
little bit more now and i thank you very
much for the question representative
burroughs
okay anybody else
see none oh yes so we have your your co
my compatriot
patriot
thank you mr chair and hello everyone my
name is dennis acton i'm
on the health and human services
committee and i represent rockingham
district 10 fremont and um so sue came
to me with this bill and
i i know a little bit about pharmacies
um but i started delving into it and
didn't like what what i found and and
so basically um this piece of
legislation i think is a first step in
addressing some of these issues that are
causing high prices so just to
to um
bring you into the actual legislation um
some of the the points that were talking
about that that sue introduced uh
basically if we go to page five
line 35
this is a list of regulation of pharmacy
benefit managers now and once again
like sue reiterated we usually aren't
introducing more licensing we're usually
trying to to make it more efficient and
so forth but we feel that th this
problem has risen to that level that
that needs to be to to give us the
mechanism to to impose these um these
regulations here but basically uh so we
have um sections one two three
and and four and five here but basically
this is where you'll find um the
solutions to the problems of like say
with number one we have um
pbms are actually penalizing
pharmacists for giving pricing options
to their customers so they're to the to
the patients so that we're seeing that
patients are actually paying more and
not able to even be told that there's
there may be a generic and and that's
just wrong in in this especially
we call that the gag clause and i
thought we yeah well again we passed
last
last year the gag law was passed um it's
still a problem that needs to be
addressed um according to the the people
the experts that i've talked to so
um
but once again uh and there's a problem
with prior approvals um
and and so forth so that's that address
that's addressed in there um the other
the other problem is obviously the use
of rebates and and how that's
become a convoluted process that's not
it
so much of this doesn't
help the patient it hurts the patient
that's that's what we're trying to
change and then there's also the process
of clawbacks where the pharmacy will
submit their claim to the pbm
from the patient and they'll the pbm
will say yes we'll pay ten dollars for
that then they'll go and do further
research and then say no now where else
absolutely i'm gonna pay seven dollars
for that and they claw back three
dollars
from a future payment uh
reimbursement to the um the pharmacy we
we feel that that's wrong
we feel that when the claim is is paid
there should be final and that's that's
addressing number two
and um
you know so
it goes on for for a bunch of points
there that you can read for yourself and
things that we'll um we'll be looking
into in the future
and then the second point is actually
page eight
line one
and that's the freedom of consumer
choice for pharmacy now this could be
its own standalone bill
in the future but um
this is this deals with the the vertical
integration that we see where the the
insurance company owns the the pharmacy
and they they
they control the whole pipeline and what
they do is they
penalize people if they go out if the
patient goes to another pharmacy outside
of that vertical market they pay they
actually pay more but they're not told
about that and i feel that that
that is shouldn't
shouldn't be allowed once again it's
everything is working against the
patient where it should be the opposite
that's what i feel we should be working
for
so these points here in in the
freedom of consumer
choice for pharmacy deal with that very
problem of being able to choose where
you want to go and not be penalized by
the pbm
so that's basically it for for what i
have to say certainly any final
questions um we're realistic about this
we know uh but this is the beginning of
an issue that we want to address if we
win our re-elections we'll be back to
the visit and you'll be so lucky
[Laughter]
so where did you get the language for
this bill
where did you
this language came from uh originally
from legislation that was
so i would say the very first bill
that
i was chairman and i got overturned on
the house floor
was
to allow
new hampshire pharmacists to be able to
uh get the
uh fulfill a prescription at the same
price
in compensation
and this was 30 years ago so it was
that donald lee lozo was
overturned me on the floor on this issue
so because it was considered a mandate
but so i would say
not with standing with ohio but in new
hampshire this has been a law for a very
long time
so
so some of these issues might be true
you know in ohio but i would say a lot
of these issues you know like i say the
clawbacks and the and the and the gag
rule and we've we've addressed all these
issues already in the past but it is
always nice to revisit the issues and
see see what's out there so thank you
for bringing this bill to us
any questions from the committee members
seeing none we thank you very much for
your testimony thank you all for your
time yes definitely thank you for your
time
uh
okay i got another tag team here uh
curtis berry and
sam hillman who represent the
pbm
entities
good afternoon mr chairman good
afternoon close enough
uh
thank you for the opportunity i'm curtis
barry here on behalf of the
what's known as pcma the pharmaceutical
care management association which is the
national trade association for the pbm
industry
pharmacy benefit manager uh which is the
the uh the acronym or the what the
acronym stands for
chairman hunt sam holomyer here with
pcma uh thank you for the rest of the
committee for allowing me to present
today as well
um i think i'd like to start with um a
little bit of data to respond to one of
the the last comments which we hear all
the time about the squeeze on
independent pharmacies uh i did a little
research earlier in the week
looking at the board of pharmacies
website
there currently are 255
retail pharmacy locations here in the
state of new hampshire that does not
include a hospital pharmacy
255.
one for if my math was right every 3 500
people or something it's pretty healthy
and it's growing
as far as the independence go within the
last 24 months according to the minutes
of the board of pharmacy
they've approved five new retail
pharmacy locations
only one of them was a chain
food for thought
i always thought the reason why some of
those are retiring they're just retiring
they're getting old and they're they're
all done
compounding well you know there was a
point in time when you could say you
know who is it or why is it the
independents are going out of business
if you have a chain come along and say
hey mr pharmacist we're going to give
you a boatload of money you can take
four weeks of vacation every year and
you can be a pharmacist instead of
running a business you know who's going
to say no
but back to the bill at hand
i hope you all had an opportunity to
look at the email i had sent over the
weekend which was give a little bit of a
primer on what a pbm is what its
function is what it does
pbms serve their client entities to
lower the prescription drug benefit for
those entities now it's an an entity
that i think is lost in a lot of these
conversations quite frequently we talked
about the pharmacy we talked about the
pbm we talked about the manufacturer
we don't talk about the folks that are
paying the premium
that are passing along some of the
premium to their employees because the
costs continue to increase the pbm
serves to keep that cost as low as
possible and the employer then is able
to pass along some of the cost savings
to their employees as best they can but
it's their decision we have to please
keep in mind the folks that pay the
bills
pbms do that
in a number of ways they provide a
number of services which was on the on
the chart
which also serves the the patient as
well
things like 24 7
pharmacists at the other end of a phone
uh drug utilization review
looking at a customers or a patient's
prescriptions to make sure there's
there's no conflicting
prescriptions but at its core the pbm
negotiates
for lower drug prices with the
manufacturer
and you can imagine the leverage of pbm
has representing tens of millions of
lives versus an entity like the state of
new hampshire which has tens of
thousands of lives the pbm has much
better opportunity to drive the prices
down
and the state of new hampshire does by
the way contract with a pbm to perform
it those services on behalf of the state
employees health plan
um
so to get into some of the bill
specifics i'd like to just go a little
bit in order
uh we think that many of these
provisions are all
duplicative with what's in place but
many of them also are new and will
remove those tools from the toolbox that
the pbms use to lower the prices
and it is several different pieces all
in in one piece of legislation
so when you get into the policy sections
n3 and n5 near the beginning and near
the end
the licensure and registration as you
mentioned mr chair
2019 senate bill 226
established a beefier registration
process and reporting to the department
of insurance
that's fairly new
that's already in statute
there are some references to audits in
this bill in 1580
regulation or oversight of audits and in
pharmacy rights in
relative to audits was covered
uh in 2013 by legislation and amended as
recently as 2 as 2020
and that's in the pharmacy statute
then we get into n4 which has a number
of different parts roman one
this was just mentioned would allow a
pharmacist to let a patient know about a
lower cost option
this was addressed uh 2018
in house bill 1719 and established that
the contract between an insurance
carrier or a pbm and a contract to
pharmacy shall not contain a provision
prohibiting a pharmacist from from
providing certain information to the
insured party that's covered
roman 2 n4
the language appears to
link
a copay
with the pharmacy reimbursement
these are two transactions that really
don't have anything to do with each
other the copay is a function of a
benefit design the employer
or the
benefit provider
will establish a copay based upon what
they wish to do with for their employees
higher co-pays lower co-pays the
pharmacy reimbursement is a contract
contracted
transaction between
the entity the pbm or the carrier and
the pharmacy they really don't have any
interaction there
the next several sections
create
in reality a new mandated reimbursement
mechanism that on its face is price
fixing we're establishing in statute how
much somebody's going to get paid for
something
the pcma analysis for this is that it
will cost new hampshire employers and
families if it's passed on 78 million
dollars a year
i think that's
plain and simple for these several
sections
um a few sections after that
oh i'm sorry um
that was
n4
romans
6 through 9 i believe
this is the one that susan was referring
to that was the average price plus 10.95
correct
so one of the confusing parts i should
mention is that there's a slight
typo in the drafting there are two
sections n4
um
but um
that would be early on
i think it's page
eight starting on page six
page 6 line 28
for for that piece and that goes through
[Music]
right
the next page middle of the the next
page
the next subject
that the bill covers is a prohibition on
what's called performance-based
contracts or value-based purchasing
agreements
rather than paying a reimbursement for a
pharmacy for volume
the reimbursement
model is for performance we want to make
sure
patients are getting in and taking
medication there are many metrics uh
that we'd like to make reimbursement on
and this section would do away with that
under the bill
pbm could not
make sure a pharmacy is accountable for
using the proper tools
it's cost effective for the patient and
the payer as well
again
in the next end for is duplicative
this is what the chair reference says
the any willing provider statute
been on the books for 30 years in
essence it says that any pharmacy that's
willing to agree to the terms and
conditions must be led into the network
in addition the
department of insurance has fairly
robust network adequacy requirements
that were recently
reviewed in revamped i guess you would
say
maybe three or four years ago
that's
duplicative as well
so the sum of it is
many portions of the bill are
duplicative
or they interfere in and have the state
step into the provisions of a contract
that's negotiated between two private
entities
um
there are a few pieces that touch on
could touch on erisa preemptions as well
that's been the subject of
both legislation and court cases
several court cases ongoing
which if the state this state were the
way into it could be a pro costly
proposition in and of itself so
i'm happy to answer questions i don't
know if sam you want to add anything
any questions
seen done well i guess you got off easy
we'll be around if they're if questions
do come up yep
uh i have one more card left tyler
brennan from the insurance department
that takes no position
tyler brennan life and health director
with the new hampshire insurance
department and right we don't have a
position um
by way of background the insurance
department has regulated a little closer
thank you thanks
by way of background the insurance
department has regulated pvms as a part
of the insurance company's operations
so on more recent years we started to
define them and provide specific
requirements that apply to pbms in the
insurance code but um but it's never
that we haven't regulated them that
being said they've been subject to
insurance insurance laws when they've
been administering benefits for fully
insured products
so um
a few years ago we defined pvm and chat
in the statute then we created a new
chapter which had most of the same
requirements that were already in the
insurance statute and called the pbm
chapter and that's what created the
registration requirements
this bill has a lot of new provisions
one of the things that was done very
carefully when that new chapter was
created was to define pbm so that
applied only to fully insured business
the definition that's in this
legislation does not do the same thing
so it assumedly brings in the
self-insured side of things as well and
it was already mentioned but the ruling
versus pcma supreme court decision was a
bit of a surprise for some of us it had
to do with the amounts that pharmacies
were paid and saying yeah states can
actually regulate that when the pbm is
operating that way that being said to
the extent that you're looking at
regulating pbms you still have to be
careful about federal preemption
and obviously if something is at odds
with erisa preemption it could
invalidate the whole new legislation or
the whole new chapter
when i looked through a lot of the more
controversial areas of the bill and
kurds did go through most of them one of
them as it relates to network adequacy
is actually a good example of something
that would be preempted i mean that goes
to the benefit design that is beyond
kind of the state
doing something in terms of
reimbursement rates to pharmacies
there are a number of other provisions
that are in there that could be
considered controversial they've come to
this committee in separate legislation
in a number of different ways and
among them are how much that
reimbursement would go to the particular
provider and
most of these i think that curtis did
mention but no pharmacy tiering is
another one
reduction in cost sharing for use of
mail order and then there are
jurisdiction issues so it makes
reference to new hampshire residents the
way we regulate insurance it deals with
whether or not the policy is cited to
new hampshire think the employer's
headquarters is in new hampshire or
you work at a bricks and mortar location
so if you're a new hampshire resident
but you work in massachusetts you get
your insurance through blue cross blue
shield of massachusetts that's not
something that's not a policy subject to
our jurisdiction so that creates some
some issues on that front
one of the things that was added to that
pbm registration chapter at the request
of the insurance department was the
ability for the insurance department to
build a pbm directly for market conduct
examination
remember everything we do as a regulator
goes through the insurance company so
there has been a certain amount of
tension between some insurance companies
and their pbm over the years and that's
one of the reasons that some insurers
are now owning their own pbms and
maintaining a bit more control so if the
pbm was doing something wrong the
carrier is technically responsible for
what the pvm is doing we would issue a
market conduct examination to the
carrier we would build a carrier for
that examination but the reality is the
pbm is the one we should be targeting
those efforts at so as a part of the new
chapter there was a section saying the
insurance department can bill the pbm
directly for that market conduct exam so
if you do decide to proceed with this
this bill and pass it we would request
that that that provision
be added to um to the legislation
um
happy to take any questions you would
have
okay any questions for tyler
none thank you tyler thank you
i do have one more card left heidi crawl
represents
a hip
in opposition to the bill
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is heidi kroll i work at gallagher
callahan and gartrell and i represent
ahip which is america's health insurance
plans um
we agree with
much of the testimony that
pcma has provided to you today so i'm
not going to repeat any of that there is
only one
provision that i wanted to kind of
highlight for you and i do have
testimony that's being handed around
so limiting my comments to the proposed
section
on page six
lines fourteen to twenty four
deal relating to the 340 b discount drug
pricing program
and there is a
fact sheet that we've included behind
the testimony
so house bill 1580 would require
reimbursement to a 340b entity
for drugs that are purchased at a deep
discounts under the federal program
um at a rate at least as great as that
paid to non-340b entities that are not
entitled to purchase those drugs at the
deep um federal
program discounts and so the bills
provisions essentially guarantee in
state law
some pretty outrageous price profits
that were recently found in a study
called examining hospital trace price
transparency drug profits and the 340b
program
and you know we're concerned about this
section because as the study found that
340b hospitals often charge their cash
paying customers meaning the uninsured
the same as the median price for
commercial carriers which was found to
be about approximately 400 percent of
their cost
and that's there's that's included in
the attachment so
we would support
inexpedient to legislate on this piece
of legislation and that provision is
particularly concerning so i thank you
for your time and
thank you very much
questions seeing oh representative no
you're all set okay representative abel
has a question
yes uh thank you thank you for
testifying um just to
uh be clear
um
you're you're uh
opposed to the bill
and you believe that the current system
is is doing a better job than what would
than what would happen if this bill were
passed or maybe you could elaborate
slightly on that
sure i mean i think as you've heard from
the prior testimony
there's been a lot of
work over the years in terms of passing
various pieces of legislation that put
into place
the registration and reporting
requirements and the gag clause and
any willing provider and so i think
i think that in most cases the
each section of this bill has already
been addressed elsewhere in new
hampshire law or or rules
thank you
all right oh representative herbert you
really have a question
you can talk to her afterwards
she wasn't signed up to testify
well i i wanted to because i know that
they brought
in house
the pbm
since the last time we were discussing
this legislation so i would like to get
a feel for
the difference
do you ready to make that presentation
paul
thank you mr chairman and
representative
here's the issue anthem does own its own
pbm it's called ingenio rx
uh this is not a typical i believe cigna
i don't know whether the signal rep is
here in the room but i think they own
express scripts
and i think as tyler indicated
the bringing in house
a pbm gives the carrier more control
over their pbm and then of course they
can sell those services
to others so they not only serve their
own population
and have better care management with
their members in that regard but they
also sell their services externally
and so that's anthem's pbm the one
interesting thing i might add to
anything that's been said here i know
that people are struggling with the
concept of well how do you get a hold of
drug pricing well you begin somewhere
and it's probably at the top with the
manufacturers and yes the pbms
downstream are making money there's no
doubt about it but it's very hard to
weigh what they do and think about well
what sort of profits do they really
deserve i could never answer that
question but new hampshire last
two was a year before last
established a drug affordability board
and so right now some of your
compatriots senators and
appointees to this drug affordability
board are doing what a lot of states are
doing and are now really looking
directly at what they can do
to bring certain drugs down into an
affordability range for purchase in the
state and i think we're going to have to
start looking at ways to do that in a
very aggressive fashion going forward
the regulatory scene here i think tyler
explained the department is new to their
registration format
this is more a licensure format but i
haven't really read the bill closely but
as i heard curtis berry going through it
clearly there are some provisions in
there which seem
contrary to what we would really want to
happen here and it's important that you
look at all the things that we have done
as representative hunt pointed to where
we've really made some strides that that
bill would think we had not yet covered
so it's a huge huge issue and it's ten
after three and you've been here since
nine o'clock so unless you have
questions thank you thank you thank you
very much paul
okay having no more cards uh 1580 yes uh
lindsay nitto who's not here from cigna
is in opposition to the bill
and
uh there was one support in five opposed
on the blue sheets
this goes to show who knows where these
are coming from
with that i will close the public
hearing
you